there's no time
the time is 13. o'clock
hey everybody it's saturday and we are
back there again
yeah last night we went out to the club
man i am so tired
yeah yeah we were supposed to get some
pookie videos today for uh for the break
in the middle and
[ __ ] the camera went out we did we
couldn't do it i could have done it on
the phone but
i was busy cooking meatloaf yeah you
made meatloaf we just had some like
right
like just a couple minutes ago i didn't
want to do the show on an episode like i
haven't eaten today
yeah that's true i'm trying to lose some
of this fat so i can get some of that
muscle definition
[Music]
yeah i don't think a big pile of
meatloaf and mashed potatoes is
going to help you with that goal
necessarily yeah
it's all that protein it was good though
though i was still under i'm still
under 2 000 calories a day yeah yeah
well yeah
you throw the booze in there though well
yeah that's what i mean just you know
you don't you like you don't think about
[ __ ] how much that is
like you know i got a i got a package
today that [ __ ] astounded me it was
from new york
yeah or yeah yeah it's new york right
yeah i think it is from new york yes it
is that's from
um that's from elsa elsa yeah it was one
of our patreon show with the show
show her what show them once should i
share the whole box you got me a whole
[ __ ] case of that damn mexican hot
i'm just gonna take this man the l
yeah there's how many boxes yeah yeah
um and that's the brown one two three
four five there's a lot of bottles
yeah there's at least 10 of them in
there your ass is going to be on fire
for the next year or two
that's that's enough to get me through
the [ __ ] the the jehovah's apocalypse
that's right you will still have a cure
that'll carry cover that'll [ __ ] burn
anything out
any virus any bacteria you got nothing
can cohabitate
your system after you've getting that
[ __ ] show them show them again this i
believe
i believe this [ __ ] here what's it
called it i gotta read it it's got some
mayan writing on there
extra extra extra hot with three x's
yeah it's got what's called uh
this one this one doesn't have the
the little font on some some models that
is it's called
ithaca booty it it'll [ __ ] your booty up
that's what it'll say on there this is
the brown one right yeah
anal apocalypse yeah it's [ __ ] fancy
look at that mayan extra hot
yeah because really kind of the only
place you can get that around here
there's like a little bitty
mexican store like bodega or something
like that that's like way over in eustis
and you
you know you said that you well
sometimes it shows up in um
a walmart but every now and then it goes
fast yeah
usually the one at walmart is the is the
is the red one yeah the red one and the
green one
uh but the brown one and they got they
got like 10 different flavors this
this yucca uh el yucateco man this is a
good brand
and kanavatsalan down there in [ __ ]
tijuana hill hill vouch this is this is
this is their top one
that's the real [ __ ] that's the real
[ __ ] i can't eat that my stomach would
like
hurt you yeah i love it i know i know
but like i said i'm not a real big i
don't mind like some spicy food but
mostly i just i mostly i want to taste
my food i don't want to endure it
you know what i'm saying when this first
appeared in the united states about 10
years ago
that's when i first saw it it was twice
as hot
yeah they they tamed it down yeah
it was so hot just like one drop you
couldn't eat it
but now i could i can put it on a taco
make a whole line of it yeah it'll [ __ ]
you up but i can eat it
it's good well don't they say like even
like indian and thai restaurants and
stuff like that they always say
like um if you're like a white person
and you go in there to eat you have to
tell them if you want it like super
super hot you have to say
i want this like thai hot or i want this
indian hot
because if you just say you want it hot
they'll just make it white person hot
which that isn't all that hot
i've heard that i'm not there's
stereotype that white people don't like
hot food
i think that might have applied like my
dad's generation yeah that was like a
long time ago but
i do feel like that that and
specifically i think that was like an
old
midwesterner thing like where they would
make jokes it's like even ketchup is too
spicy for them because all their food is
so bland
get that pepper on me oh my god yeah
i would die without black pepper i put
that [ __ ] on everything midwest is all
like scandinavian descent
descended people so you know what i mean
they don't they don't have spice in
scandinavia
you know i've seen their i've seen what
they cook matter of fact
when we were kids they still had those
[ __ ] swedish smorgasbords
yeah yeah i remember those land is [ __ ]
everything
all those swedish meatballs are good
i'll get it yeah i'll get it for those
yeah
yeah but those little things like our
grandparents went to that [ __ ]
and they were like oh those spicy
swedish meatballs
yeah we're trying like what are you
talking about that's like really really
funny
i mean but you know it's it's i was just
thinking while you're saying about the
scandinavian food i was thinking about
that [ __ ] episode of kitchen
nightmares where they went to
fleming's flaming which was danish it
was supposed to be like a danish
restaurant but it was in miami of all
places
yeah which that would never sell here
yeah it wasn't selling and the food
looked
uh horrific yeah and it was all old
people and they're eating it and the
walls were pink it looked like it was
awful yeah
[ __ ] they were making little [ __ ]
foil baskets with swans and [ __ ] for
their taste that's right that was the
lady that made the foil swans
yeah it was just a bunch of [ __ ] 80
90 year old women in [ __ ]
pink sweaters and [ __ ] you know all
those pastel colors and [ __ ]
that is one of my favorite episodes and
what was funny is that
they had a [ __ ] a a a [ __ ] cuban
chef
i think he was cuban wasn't he he was i
think he was cute well yeah it's miami
so yeah yeah yeah he was a cuban chef
and [ __ ] they're like they're just
like i don't think gordon is like
you cook this [ __ ] and he's like yeah
and he goes
is it good he goes no he's like no it's
not good that's nice
it's [ __ ] it's danish what's that you
know i said yeah
he goes can you cook cuban food he goes
yeah and he was a [ __ ] badass
cuban chef they changed that [ __ ] to
cuban food and it was [ __ ] selling
like hotcakes well like i said it's
miami because it was miami
that's like because cuban food is no
[ __ ] joke man those sandwiches those
cuban sandwiches
man mojito that was my favorite thing
when i lived in tampa was cuba
yeah cuban sandwiches you could get them
anywhere
although growing up in brazil brazilian
food's good too man feijoada
yeah cochinia they had all kinds of
little pastas
which all these little [ __ ] saga
jeans which are little salties little
salty foods like little
stuff you get out of the fast food you
know it's good stuff
real good [ __ ]
show hostile which is brazilian barbecue
it's unbeatable yeah
unbeatable one of these days well we'll
have to we have one here yeah there's a
there's a couple of there's a couple of
texas to brazil
yeah brazil's texas that's what they're
talking about
i mean no united states knows where it
is a [ __ ]
it's like a brazilian gaucho [ __ ]
barbecue place
it doesn't have to red tomato sauce not
like barbecue sauce it's just salted
meat
cooked over barbecue with [ __ ] like
um
what do you call it oh [ __ ] i forgot the
word
it's just chopped up um
onions peppers and um uh
uh tomatoes with little olive oil what
they call it
vinaigrette yeah and you eat that with
it man and
something called fadofa which is like
real cracked wheat barley type of stuff
that you it looks like sawdust you
sprinkle it over that meat that actually
sounds really good it's good because
it's kind of slightly crushed
crunchy yeah some people [ __ ] mistook
it i saw some white people trying to eat
that didn't know what it was they're
adding water to it they thought they
were making
oatmeal or something yeah i thought it
was farofa
or no farina oh yeah because they called
it farofa so they said well farina okay
they added a lot of water
they said no no no it's like cream of
wheat yeah no it's just the [ __ ]
topping
it gives up a little bit of a crunch
it's good sometimes they have little
diced up hard-boiled eggs in it
and you get it you put it on there and
it gives it and it's kind of has eggs
are good enough it kind of has like a
vague malty flavor it's good yeah
yeah it's good zach says believe it or
not tom tacos are actually super popular
in norway
really interesting i'm surprised i want
we'll have to [ __ ] well the world is a
lot different that's different it's
changed in the past ten years
and i mean we need to finish watching
that taco chronicle show that show is
fascinating yeah it's like two seasons
internet has really kind of removed all
the damn
gatekeepers everybody can see other
people's foods and now you know what's
good and what's bad you can just see it
yeah actually like
i want me some of that like what they're
eating in [ __ ] mainland china you
don't want any of that
you don't want to eat that yeah though
china chinese food is so great no no no
american chinese american chinese food
is great
not chinese chinese food everything's
got the head on it's got the guts still
inside of it they're eating [ __ ]
raw frogs alive and [ __ ] no no
yeah we need to eat things we knew a
girl that like uh she didn't live in
china but she went there for a while
like in
kind of like a backwoods show she had
like a long job over there and she was
like yeah she didn't
she's like the food over there it's not
really not good
no it's probably not bad in places like
taiwan and
maybe hong kong getting them in where i
think you have a little bit more
culinary kind of expertise and better
standards well it's just like anything
else like in a bigger city you're going
to get like a more
like out in the out in the country
you're not going to get i'm not going to
piss off any mainland
mainland chinese but i really give a
[ __ ] about your feelings uh
i've heard that if you really want to
experience china you go to taiwan
that's like rich china yeah that's like
yeah that's like china that has
everything
[Laughter]
you know china that [ __ ] understands
what food quality is they say taiwan's
[ __ ] nice
yeah i've heard that as well good club
life and [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah probably pretty fun yeah we
just what do we always end up talking
about food i don't know
which like i said we need to just do a
whole food show we're gonna do the
cookbook eventually but yeah
we're gonna um do a show today about
emperor caligula caligula and this is a
true crime show
why the [ __ ] are we talking about an
ancient imperial roman
or ancient roman em empire or haitian
[ __ ] what am i just starting to drink i
know it's like you're not even drunk
what's your excuse
you have to understand that caligula was
from a crime family and he grew up
in the clutches of some evil [ __ ]
criminals [ __ ]
it's like some [ __ ] out of a serial
killer and he ended up
becoming an emperor and did some weird
ass [ __ ]
there's gonna be some caveats you know
what i mean in the show it's been a long
time since i've actually
read english translations of [ __ ]
roman history like cytonius and stuff
you know i've read and there was the
other historian i forgot was now there
were two main historians that talked
about suetonius did
um cassie's d.o talked about him i think
um
there's always a variation in how
they describe anything in history roman
history is fake news
um what you're reading had a lot to do
with who commissioned the history book
if you got commissioned to write a
history by some rich
roman aristocrat the last thing you were
going to do
was slander that aristocrats family and
especially if they had ever been in
politics
and you couldn't talk bad about the
[ __ ] reigning emperor
because even though
even though rome was a western
civilization it wasn't like the united
states that didn't have freedom of
speech if you said the wrong thing you'd
[ __ ] your ass and [ __ ] get killed
it was kind of like it's kind of like
america
in a way but but worse imagine if it was
run by crime families which i think it
might be already
but they were more degenerate than we
are
and um you know they these child islands
men and all that kind of [ __ ] you're
going to see you're going to see we're
going to talk about it
yeah and it's like the thing about it is
that i mean it happened two thousand
years ago and it's like and i'm not
saying calicula wasn't a monster because
he probably was
yeah but some of the stuff about him
that is kind of common knowledge about
caligula
might not be true or might have like a
different
spin spin on or have happened in a
different context than what yeah
what what he was terrible though you
know what you
tend to see in roman written histories
and that's a histories plural because
there are
many historians during that period
you see them agreeing on certain dates
and you agree
and they agree that certain things
happened but they tend to disagree on
the cause the motive and who was to
blame and
you know politics were involved politics
had a spin a lot of rome had
a two-party system it was the optimates
and the demagogues i forgot what
uh which were kind of like the democrats
and the republicans are very much the
same thing
they were also called the whites and the
reds there was [ __ ] political battles
in the streets political assassinations
paid
rioters uh [ __ ] everything that you
see today and what's happened right now
the united states rome had that
they were sophisticated people and
i could read uh read english
translations because i don't speak i
speak portuguese which is real close to
latin
it is a latin type language but my latin
isn't good enough i can't
i have to read an english translation of
it
and i can read you know reports back to
rome from
from uh julius you know julius caesar
while he was out in gaul trying to
conquer new [ __ ] territories he's
talking about his military operations
and it's just like a modern military man
[ __ ] talk i
is writing it i can get a feel for what
the mission was like
what true morale was like what it would
be like to serve under julius
it's weird you know even though it's 2
000 years ago
because we have so much of a common
culture and it's a western civilization
you know exactly what he's talking about
you can even get it you can even get a
feel for the author
and what the author is thinking yeah and
that's not really the case say like
whether
chinese writings from 2000 years ago or
japanese writings even from 500 years
ago
because of the cultural disconnect you
can't really get a good feel for the
person
yeah the written language has a lot to
do with thought and thought and language
really are very much combined
and directly translating from one
language to another and across
cultures man it's hard if you're not
talking about western civilization
sometimes
yeah you know well because you don't
have any like frame you don't have the
reference you don't have the
cultural frame of reference you know
yeah and
but when you when you're so when you
when you talk about the weird [ __ ] that
caligula
did or supposedly did you have to
understand it they were as tripped out
about it as we were
well yeah that's why people are still
talking about them nowadays yeah she
wasn't right
she wasn't right she wasn't right
okay and somebody has and oracles that
uh asked
caligula wasn't actually his name was it
that's true that's not his name uh
it was a nickname given to him when it
was little boots yeah booties
yeah it basically means booties and
there's a little combat boots that he
wore when he was a child because his dad
was a war hero
yeah and one of the roman legions
saw him you know his dad presented him
in front of the legion because each
each legion was a private army that a
senator could raise
and uh the [ __ ] troops just loved
this little kid because he was dressed
he was like two or three years old and
he had like a little little soldier
uniform yeah with the little boots and
he had a little boots and they thought
he had cute little
combat boots yeah yeah now
there's some some people are saying well
it's not combat boots it was like
sandals and they had like
a combat boot version of sandals yeah
that's
what because i've seen an actual one
that they found from that time period
like an adult one not a kid they seem to
have had both
they seem to have had boots and sandals
it was kind of like a sandal but with
the
with the straps like really close
together i guess is the best way to
describe it
okay what you see pictured in statues
and in pictures is usually a dress
uniform
and with that it's samples like with the
straps that you're talking about yeah
and they found lots of those
and they wore those in certain functions
of duty you know what i mean but
evidently they also had closed toe boots
kind of like a doc martin it went up
real high you know like the yeah
went up to your knee they had that too
but i i don't think they were as common
or it was some kind of special duty
thing maybe that's what you wore up in
gall or up in
germany and they're in the winter yeah
you know they had mo
they had a decent understanding of
footwear uniforms and armor i mean they
they were pretty modern even though they
didn't have pants
which is some weird [ __ ] well maybe they
were just like maybe they invented pants
and then they were just like
yeah these are is the [ __ ]
so much more freeing well
it makes sense it makes sense to have
that toga thing that skirt thing
you know when you were down south and
near the mediterranean where it was hot
a lot yeah
but you know they were fighting up and
up in germania
you know for a long time yeah if you're
cold you don't want your dangly beds
right
and they stole the idea of pants and
shirts from from germans
and evidently galls yeah
but were they wearing them up there in
the snow i would think they probably
were
i mean you would think yeah yeah and
then when they went back to rome they
would probably want to be seen in public
walking around in german pants and
shirts
now later on you know you're like man
yeah because pants help you riding a
horse
too yeah a lot better on a saddle well
yeah i can imagine because that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up with skirt
[Laughter]
yeah because they didn't have no bbd's
or nothing they didn't have like [ __ ]
tiny ladies another thing about about
roman roman equestrians or
roman [ __ ] knights or guys that ran
had horses
they didn't have saddles they had a
saddle pad
like a blanket yeah but there was no
saddle
yeah that was a much later innovation
yeah they stole that from the germans
yeah see there's a bunch of things you
know they're always calling the germans
barbarians but the germans [ __ ]
or the germans that's a generalized term
it was just anybody who was
up in germany you know um
they would the romans called them
barbarians but they had superior
technology had better steel technology
better weapons better horse stuff
you know and even even the germans said
that so i don't i don't
necessarily think they were barbarians
in the way that you would imagine them
but they're talking about as country
people yeah that's what they're talking
about
rednecks rednecks and i ended up
becoming part of the empire in the same
way the united states swallowed up all
these little states
you know what i mean yeah and there was
indigenous people and then people moving
in there's a lot of
a lot of those germans weren't from here
they were walking in from russia
from basically where russia is now you
know yeah it's complicated
it's a long history like i said
everything's complicated everything's
complicated
but yeah something that uh that made me
laugh that uh you know caligula like i
said being a nickname
um his name was actually gaius but um
the funny thing is that i was watching
this uh documentary about it with this
british historian
and she said apparently caligula like
once he got
to be an adult i mean obviously he
didn't want to be called caligula
anymore but everybody still called it
him anyway because it like it just stuck
and so she said well that would be like
the modern equivalent of calling
somebody like
emperor didims or like emperor bootykins
or something like that
which like made me laugh so i'm like but
he was an [ __ ] so [ __ ]
you know i mean they could call him that
if you want um i had a couple other
shoutouts before we get too
deeply into the roman history
so let me do that real quick like i said
we uh we already thanked ilsa for
sending us all the hot sauce
yes um you know talking to rocket fuel
without a rocket that's what i'm saying
like
yeah yeah also we got a really nice
package from
michael yesterday which has this right
here
evil dead one and two still
book edition i am very very excited
about this
we did not have we did not have we
didn't have that one on i didn't even
have it on dvd i don't think
no but yeah so that's like super cool so
thank you very much for that
and also we have a new patron uh joe aka
dark skull so hey there and thank you
very much
um also if you're a patron remember uh
to go and vote in the polls
for next week's movie and next week's
uh topic yeah you you have until
tomorrow
yeah there's been a lot of interaction
on that you guys are helping us out
choosing next topics that's working out
i like that
yeah i like that as well you know i like
people getting more involved in it and
yeah [ __ ] like that and before we start
the show wanted to wanted to announce
that um
looks like our friend sophie might be
joining the team as a research assistant
for the show
but i don't want to give away too much
information yet
um she may be coming back
um to visit in a couple months and she
might
be doing some seasonal work for us so
we'll we'll see we'll see what's going
on i'm sure you guys will be happy to
see sophie come back
yeah it's something it's in early stages
it's in the early stages of development
early stages of development so you want
to stop
start talking go ahead and start the
show caligula go ahead and start about
[ __ ] guys ridiculous
other guys guys guys caesar augustus
germanicus
yes yeah all that germanicus stuff is
about kicking ass on germans yeah well
germanicus that was his dad's name
though so though his dad was
[ __ ] claimed a [ __ ] ton of land up in
grammaria yeah yeah and they became
provinces of rome
the roman war machine was a trip it was
a lot more honest back then
you went you waged war against people
you'd go into these areas and you say
you're all part of rome now you're gonna
pay taxes we're gonna give you some [ __ ]
if you say no we're gonna kill you burn
your [ __ ] down take all your women and
sell
your women and children and we're going
to sell them to slaves back in rome what
do you say
they'd be like nah somebody got nothing
okay die [ __ ]
they wouldn't they would die
[ __ ] was real
honest about what it was all right it
was not like the
kind of [ __ ] wars i was involved in
it was real honest we were gonna take
your [ __ ] it was a lot like piracy
and then whatever money whatever money
you spent to raise that army you
recouped it when you sold all those
slaves and all that gold back in rome
and so you could hand out bonuses to
your troops so your troops were like
looking they had high morale
because it wasn't just you're going to
survive the mission then do your tour
and do your [ __ ] 20 years and then
were also going to be
supposedly you were going to be rich you
were getting cash bonuses yeah so they
were mercenary armies
you know and they weren't really loyal
to rome they were loyal to their general
and their general was whatever senator
they put it together
if you were a senator you had to go to a
general school and then you had the
legal right to raise an army
and you usually had supporters who would
give you the money to raise the army
which started the dab war machine
they were the the romans did not have a
centralized army
so we're going to start talking about
armies are going to be mentioned in this
it's very different from an army of
today where you have an army controlled
by a federal government they didn't have
that back then
each senator had his own army they did
that because they were afraid that if a
if a republic had a centralized army
then you would elect a praetor and he
would become a dictator and use that
army to pacify the people
so you wanted to diversify and break up
all the military power amongst the
senators
so that sounds good but what that ended
up
be what that ended up doing later on was
you had
four or five roman armies fighting each
other in the [ __ ] capital
over who was the praetor and over
elections and [ __ ] like that so no it
doesn't work out
uh yes it's better if you have one army
it's better to have one army with one
dictator than [ __ ]
five armies with five wannabe dictators
fighting it out
inside your capital cities because
that's what happened
that's what that what actually happened
it's it's never a good look
government doesn't work and history
shows this over and over again it has a
half-life it
exists for a certain amount of time that
people become complacent corrupt
and then it starts to disintegrate and
then it's it's cyclical
you know you have a lot of people that
are kind of raised to believe in
fantasies like progress
there's been no example of progress in
human history
not really it might progress for 100
years or so and then it goes back and
then it goes or
it technology and knowledge might
progress but not human government
it didn't really progress that much
human nature is always the same
humans are corrupt i mean until we can
like install chips in our brains
they're not gonna do that make us better
then
[Laughter]
i think it's more in the in favor of
people that run on the show to
depopulate most of the earth because
most people are obsolete replace them
with benevolent robots like you see out
of [ __ ] prometheus and [ __ ]
alien you know and then uh you just sit
around like a potentate with a harem of
women and robot girls and then
you've inherited the earth yeah you
don't need workers anymore
but it's scary [ __ ] but life is scary as
is what life is
they're going to [ __ ] us over life
lessons from time yeah they're going to
[ __ ] us over
victor says i want to be a benevolent
robot yeah too yeah
if somebody said tomorrow that like you
could pop your brain into like a robot
body and it's like i would totally do
that
it feels better than your body well
obviously it's like if they're just
going to give me some janky old like
shitty robot body i don't want that
that'd be like the cybermen from [ __ ]
doctor who
yes you know i don't know i'm not i'm
not done with that
well it's funny just reminded me of um
saying like installing a chip
you guys have you guys ever had to
replace um
a key like from a car like in newish
cars i mean my car is old it's like a
2004.
two keys today and uh the key we didn't
lose it
but the top plastic part of it like
broke off
and like we had it glued for a while but
then like last night it just like
shattered and i guess the chip fell out
of it so we couldn't start the car
anymore
because you know they all have chips now
so i had to have like a locksmith guy
come
and they actually were able to
cut me two keys and like replace the
and you know reprogram the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] was like
almost 250 dollars 250 was that much
yeah oh [ __ ]
because like about the 200 i didn't know
about the 50. well it was 229
and then like plus tax and all that
other questions
although you know jair said that it was
a hundred dollars a key
in mexico and he said in mexico that's
like a thousand bucks it says
he said that [ __ ] hurt yeah yeah
and i mean it was like i said it got you
over to barrel man you need your [ __ ]
cage well yeah the car won't start
without it because of the [ __ ] chip
and like i guess the chip fell out of
the plastic but i mean like i said the
plastic [ __ ] on the top has been broken
for a long time
yeah but i guess last night finally the
plastic just crumbled and i don't know
where the [ __ ] chip went to
get going and it uh so it just like
[ __ ] up so i had to go
get them replaced and i was like well
while you're here like might as well get
two of them just in case
i [ __ ] lose weight so we actually
ended up with the old one and he cut me
a new one that was like a tester and
he just gave me those and he said okay
well those don't work in the ignition
but they work on the door so you might
want to like keep those just in case
like two blocked out
125 dollars a key yeah yeah yeah
well like i said i feel like i asked at
ace hardware and they said it was
75 but that but see the guy that came
today
that was he it was like a mobile
locksmith guy yeah and he said the key
was 75 but then like they had to
program it so i'm imagining that ace
probably would charge you extra to
program it as well
because they need to like pull a code
all right so all super chats will help
pay for keys
[Laughter]
i knew it was gonna be a lot but it was
just kind of like i was like
really and like i said it's like you
can't start the car without it because
you put the candidates and it just went
that's a weak salary for some people
well that was a week no that was that
was two weeks salary when i was on
unemployment
no [ __ ] that's all i can i think
no i guess it was a week but they they
just pay you every other week so it was
like 500
every other week so yeah 250 that's
unemployment yeah
couldn't really uh pay rent on that i
have to say all right let's get to the
store
yeah okay so caligula like i said not
his real name uh his name was actually
gaius
julius caesar um and he was actually
related to julius caesar this is a very
like prominent
uh roman family and like richer than
i it's like inconceivable like how much
money
like empower this family had i guess
yeah even though
when julia started this enterprise he
was broke thank you victor
thanks victor yeah julius is broke he
was
uh this would have been julius julius
caesar i think would have been his
grandfather
or great-grandfather i think it was his
great-grandfather great grandfather i
think
yeah julius uh was uh he had to raise he
he raised money by knocking on doors he
was from a patrician family
i think he was patricia and he might he
might have been a question no he thinks
patricia
and um which i guess that's kind of
complicated
roman romans had had like a caste system
if you were from a patrician family you
were from like the descendants of the
original inhabitants of the roman city
so that means you were eligible to
become
to go into the senate and become a
praetor or you know or later on an
emperor
you had to be a patrician they were like
their royal class kind of like the royal
family of england they were like that
yeah they were like from the nobles or
something yeah
and they had another class called the
equestrians
which they were basically the
descendants of people who were uh
mounted infantry officers so they were
like knights
they were like the house of lords that's
basically what they're talking about
and they had plebians that was just
regular regular poor people
i think they might have had a couple of
other ones but i don't i don't remember
uh slaves you had rum had slavery
uh and the way they handled slavery was
pretty weird
a child of a slave was a slave didn't
matter who the father was
under certain circumstances a slave
holder could free their slaves
under other circumstances the emperor or
a prator could free the slaves
there were many rome regularly pressed
to the reset button on slavery
because they were all the same basically
race they might have been a little bit
different ethnic group but over time
pretty much everybody in the roman
system
was the same they were just kind of
generic white people
and it was difficult to manage slaves
who were the same race as you
and [ __ ] the authors of the time
talked about the problems that would
happen
um so they would press the reset button
and free them pretty regularly
usually every 20 30 years they all got
freed
but then but it didn't they didn't
abolish slavery they just restarted
yeah you know they just started
enslaving more people
uh what happened later on with african
slavery was kind of a different story
but then that brought up a couple of
that brought up new problems
but it's not really inside the scope of
this but
european slavery goes back to the
[ __ ] greek golden age in the romans
and
because the american america really
united states and our union was kind of
a copy
of the greco-roman civilization it was
like a rebirth of the [ __ ] roman
republic
that's really what they were trying to
do slavery kind of
it was unconstitutional
but they understood it i guess that's a
good way to put it
because it was in the bible
and it was in all the civilizations that
they had known about before
so it wasn't strongly anti-slavery until
later when you had uh
abolition movements but rome had those
too
yeah so i guess it's been a part of
western civilization forever
the interesting thing too and
particularly during uh caligula's time
was that some people in his employ that
were well in his employ that were slaves
um actually had
a surprising amount of power like within
the
you know especially if they like over
you know people that oversaw his like
you know security team type of because
he needed to have security around him
all the time
because your ass get [ __ ] bumped off
all you know yeah back then
it was mafias pretty much right and uh
it is
older i get the more i see the the
united states is a bunch of mafias too
it's it it's it's
the bush families the clinton families
it goes back to the [ __ ] i don't
think so much the reagan but
the kennedys you're talking about
the rome the romans would have called
them mafias we we're going to call them
dynasties
yeah but rome would just call it uptown
mafia probably
well like i said it kind of happened i
mean you see it throughout european
history as well with like you're kind of
like very rich powerful families
habsburgs and
yeah all that kind of [ __ ] that same
thing over and over again nothing's
changed
that's all i was saying mankind hasn't
progressed much
you know it just hasn't
alex says i got a feeling tom is going
to be the one mainly responsible for the
show going over time tonight though yeah
that's fine
yeah i forgot i forgot i was going to
say what i was going to say about
[ __ ] julius who was caligula's
[ __ ] great grandfather i think it was
greg
well well no grandfather or great
grandfather yeah because now augustus
was his
was a great grandfather augustus was
julius's adopted
right heir they weren't totally related
but i
you're all talking about the julia
claudians yeah and they're all
interrelated and that was from julius
the claudius yeah if i remember
correctly
which was uh that lasted a long time
nearly what 80 years or something yeah
that they were in power
the julia claudians really kind of
kind of pushed the rope pushed rome down
a weird
direction you know what i mean they
never really recovered from that
but what i was going to say about about
um julius is that
he didn't have any money he started off
a poor nobleman
and he raised the money by knocking on
doors and he ended up buying a seat
as a senate as a senator uh because he
you just they were pretty honest about
it you you had to buy the seat you
didn't [ __ ]
they didn't worry about elections yeah
if you had the money you could have it
if the seat was open
and uh he julius tried to [ __ ] become
powerful in the senate and [ __ ] the
older one he was young you know
and the the older ones were punking him
out and trying to give him [ __ ]
ridiculous jobs like we're gonna put him
in charge of the [ __ ]
roadways and the [ __ ] gutters on the
sides of the roads and the back alleys
and
we're gonna put you in charge of the
[ __ ] uh abandoned forests outside
they just [ __ ] with it like that and
really i think that pissed him off to
eventually
he decided to just steal money
he got in charge of the damn circus
maximus which was like their race track
and he evidently stole every bit of bar
gold from the treasury there and
replaced with lead that had been
coated in gold and bought a [ __ ]
that's what you do
you know if you see an opportunity like
that you take it
and that's what he did because that's
what they're doing okay
and he used that money to [ __ ] become
a general and buy a damn army and went
out to conquer a bunch of land
and then when they told him to cough
that army up after he's like no i'm but
i'm coming back
don't worry no no no leave your army
outside
you know [ __ ] don't don't cross the
danube you know i don't remember the
name of the damn river
oh i'll be there hold on i would you say
you know he's [ __ ] sending letters
back like he didn't understand what was
said you know and as soon as he the
rubicon that's what it is yeah
once he crossed that rubicon he said the
die has been cast
he went down there and [ __ ] whipped
ass and took over
but it that's a very simplified version
there was already a civil war going on
uh
pompey and some other guys were down in
[ __ ] rome fighting for control it's
kind of just
disputed elections i guess you know so
uh julius was gonna [ __ ] set [ __ ]
straight and put himself in charge like
[ __ ] like you should do
you know i'm the boss this is some
disgrace everyone has to do what i
yeah this shit's all disputed so i'm
taking over
[Laughter]
which we may see some of that [ __ ] going
on in this election we'll see how it
goes
well i mean prior to this i mean
because when people think about uh you
know ancient rome it's like it was a
republic for a very long time but it's
like
caligula ended up being the third uh
roman emperor
and actually fun fact the first one that
was assassinated
spoiler alert yeah because julius was
assassinated but he wasn't really an
emperor
right he was a dictator he was a
um i don't even think he was ever
elected as a praetor he was kind of like
an
he was a a an emergency military leader
and i believe he actually called himself
dictator
and um he did pretty well but then he
got assassinated because he was too
popular wasn't
sharing power with the other senators
and his
his heir augustus hunted down
all the assassins [ __ ] brought them
all to justice the the roman people were
furious
at at um julius's assassination he was
wildly popular
so he hunted down all the assassins and
[ __ ] they had a huge party big
bonfire
where they put the body of [ __ ]
julius up on there and burned him and
then um
once he hunted them all down and it was
like a little civil war that went on
then um augustus declared himself
emperor he was the first emperor
yeah imperator
and but you know what's funny is that
knowing how the romans were
it was probably augustus that killed
julius
well see that's the thing that's the way
they were it's like there's so much of
that going on that like nobody in
ancient rome could die
without somebody going somebody poisoned
that [ __ ] yeah well they were
doing that though
that's what i mean it was like so
commonplace they were
a very effective and very intelligent
people that knew the situation they knew
they could get away with [ __ ] they did
it
and they came from a culture where you
were supposed to do that it was a roman
virtue
uh which i think that's that confuses a
lot of people
it's very much like something you'd see
in the italian mafia today
yeah that's exactly such essentially
exactly what it is it's like wait a
minute you have power and you didn't
wield it
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] you lack virtue
you know
wait a minute you had you had an
opportunity to murder that guy and you
didn't
oh you suck get out get [ __ ] out of you
[Laughter]
roman roman virtue you don't know what
anything works roman masculine virtue
was
this will explain really how this shit's
gonna we're gonna tell you what caligula
did it'll make more sense if
if you understand the culture and their
and their value system
male virtue was about hierarchy
who was above other who was above who
in the pecking order
the higher you wore were the more power
you had over other people
your strength came from your ability to
punish
enemies ruthlessly and to protect
your friends and supporters you were
supposed to be loyal to your friends
and terrible and ferocious to your
enemies there wasn't any of this
christian values of turning the other
cheek and
[ __ ] no they didn't play that if if
someone wronged you
it behooved you to pay that person back
seven fold or 77 fold you know i mean
that's that's the way it was so no one
would [ __ ] with you so no one would ever
[ __ ] with you again
except except somebody did yeah well the
thing is is that you weren't the only
bad ass out that's what i mean there's
always a bigger fish
rome was not a fish tank okay rome was a
shark tank
and it bred people like that and uh but
they were very intelligent these
people were not stupid you all you did
is read their writings they were [ __ ]
in some ways they were better than us
and star trek the original series kind
of
got into that remember when they go to
the [ __ ] other planet it's a lot like
a modern-day rome
yeah and he's even capturing [ __ ]
federation officers and turned them into
slaves
by using mind manipulation and [ __ ]
being [ __ ] sneaky and [ __ ] the romans
were like that or a good roman was like
that
well in the interesting one the
interesting thing about caligula
and then later nero was that
you know even though you had this
situation where that was seen as like a
good thing
like a lot of the you know machinations
and stuff like that that people would
probably like condemn now
um but the fact that was was like okay
but the fact that caligula
and nero stood out in particular as
being like
egregiously terrible even though
i mean you could say that they didn't do
anything i was i don't know if i'd say
they didn't do anything that much worse
than other people
than other people in their same position
but it's interesting that
they got the reputation of being that
much worse even in that
you know even in that whole like
framework of like everyone was kind of
terrible
zack saying augustic looked just like
that he got a huge crush on daniel craig
the roman the romans surprised me yeah
the romans were all about style you know
what i mean high-ranking man
uh he had to be very stylish they
tweezed their body hairs and stuff and
never [ __ ] did their hair the right
way and wore all these [ __ ]
fantastic clothes and they could write
and [ __ ] do all kinds of [ __ ]
poetry and
play instruments you know they were
holistic you know
they they were like count dante they
believed in the power of
creation and destruction and you know
the whole idea was that yeah you know
not only not only can i play the liar i
can watch my enemies
get they're beheaded while i'm playing
yeah it's all just it's all just the
same thing to me
man you know that's the way they were
which
okay it was a culture it was a gangster
type culture
it was yeah it definitely was yeah and
and uh yeah by all
by all you know by the accounts of the
statues
the high quality statues were supposed
to be pretty accurate and there is some
consistency between you know there are i
think there are a couple
cases where you had high quality statues
of the same person and they do
that's evidently how they look like
there was consistency between the two
statues but
yeah they were aesthetically good
looking even by today's standards uh
except caligula wasn't
no everybody said he was like a real
tall skinny weedy
boy dude and he kind of like leaned into
the ugliness
yeah they said that he wanted to look
not saying they were all good looking i
was just saying that the good looking
ones were as good-looking as
as a good-looking person today by the
way standards they had today's
they had modern standards of aesthetic
beauty
i mean because when you see like the the
you know statues like this one that are
supposed to be you know of caligula
nobody knows for sure
because the thing about it is that and i
saw this on this other documentary they
were talking about like they had all
these all the uh
statues of like all the different uh
emperors and they're like one thing that
they would do when they made these
statues was that they made the heads
kind of like
not removable necessarily but just like
the way that they carved it it would be
easy to like
chop the head out and like put another
one in there well they would also
repair stuff yeah that was another
another thing is is that
we we have a lot of statues and have had
statues for hundreds of years
they were in people's attics you know
what i mean rich
european people had these things in
their attics going all the way back to
the 1300s 1400s
they were and the context is lost
sometimes you don't you have a beautiful
statue of some guy you know who that is
yeah you don't know what it is
and they might have said well that must
be julius and sometimes you'll see old
books
they'll have julius caesar written under
the statue you go that's not julius
that's like commodus
or somebody else you know they're not
sure
they found an old theater one time that
had a bunch of busts of
roman emperors and it had the names so
they
were able to straighten some of them out
yeah who's who
um who was the guy that uh did the damn
coliseum the flavian ambient theater
uh i can't remember and it doesn't
matter but they have one one of the
generals
actually kind of a big smiley
[ __ ]
big smiley [ __ ] yeah
he was a good he was a good he was a
good dude i'm just kind of forgetting
what his name was
kind of a man of the people type came
from a military background and
he fixed a bunch of [ __ ] but uh nothing
lasted long in the roman empire it was
too
big too out of control not enough
technology to control things
bad record-keeping and you know you
couldn't really like
walk down the hall without getting
murdered it would have lasted a lot
longer but
well i think it depended only if you
were powerful well yeah that's what i'm
saying
yeah and that was as rome started to go
insane
yeah it took a long time for it to
decline and
and eventually kind of turned into other
you know [ __ ] your uh medieval
kingdoms
i think you know them it had tooth
its main problem was slavery that was
the problem
if he didn't have slavery in rome they
would invested more time in in
technology
because they didn't give a [ __ ] about
technology people were cheap yeah you
need labor saving devices
but you didn't have to do any labor you
had people to do that for well
if you needed machines because labor was
expensive they would start investing
more in an industry
and they would have [ __ ] stumbled all
the two things that helped america
survive which were
the telegraph and the [ __ ] steam
engine for the train
and those are two things that they
needed uh they needed that [ __ ] bad you
needed telecommunications and the
ability to
move troops and supplies out to your
borders to stop invasions before they
got inside
your borders and they didn't have that
because they were [ __ ] lazy and they
were also the ruling class was stupid
they only cared about making money right
now they didn't worry about 10-year
4 years from now 10 years from now they
didn't give a [ __ ] about barbarian
invasion
they got invaded many times they didn't
care who was in charge as long as they
were making money
yeah and that's seems to be that's the
that's the
the course of republics and empires
that's what that's what happens to him
victor mentioned greek and roman statues
were originally painted in tacky colors
yeah tacky [ __ ]
they didn't have that classy [ __ ]
marble look that was yeah they all look
classy now
yeah now that all the paint's gone no it
should look like something out of damn
persian nightclub
[ __ ] back in the day
like something out of the damn [ __ ]
graveyard out in savannah or
[Laughter]
that's something yeah all right so let's
get
back to talk about right gaius yeah we
gotta get around this dude and [ __ ]
the weird [ __ ] that he did now i think i
think it give the audience enough
background to what kind of people we're
dealing with hopefully
yeah yeah yeah so uh gaius julius caesar
better known as caligula uh born in
antiem which
nowadays is called anzio uh he was born
in actually
12 a.d now his dad
germanicus was a much-loved
war hero um like we mentioned his he's
called germanicus because
he went and killed a bunch of germans
and like took a bunch of you know got a
bunch of land and [ __ ] like that
so he was like a very well regarded uh
in the
you know among the people um and also
uh his mom was agrippina the elder now
like i said these this is from a huge
like uh you know family of people whose
names you'd recognize like i said
they were um related to augustus they
were related to julius caesar
um actually emperor nero who came along
later
was actually caligula's nephew
so these are this is all like a dynasty
of like of people
so caligula he had two brothers
uh nero andrus and he also had three
younger sisters
uh agrippina the younger julia drusilla
and julie julia
levilla or olivia i can't i don't know
how to pronounce that correctly
um and like i said he was also um
claudius was his uncle
so um one interesting thing when
when uh caligula was a kid
now his dad germanicus like i said he
was like always out on like his military
things
i think that his mom agrapena like went
with them like which was kind of unusual
i guess for like wives at the time she
was kind of
kind of badass um so she would go with
them
and like when caligula was only like two
or three years old as we mentioned
earlier
um he had he would go out with his dad
on his little like military campaigns or
whatever
and he had like a little bitty soldier's
outfit that he wore when he was a
toddler
um apparently the other soldiers thought
that was just darling
so they started calling him caligula
like we said which means
little boots and the nickname stuck
although apparently
once he got to be an emperor and an
adult he really really did not like
being called that anymore because
like that historian said it's like
calling somebody emperor bootikins
which is very very funny to me so
now uh so germanicus
caligula's dad he ended up
um dying in syria
now according to historian suetonius
probably uh he was poisoned like i said
you could nobody powerful could die
in ancient rome without somebody saying
they were poisoned or they got smothered
or whatever
um you know there's obviously no proof
of it but most historians say that
probably
somebody working for tiberius who
actually
um saw germanicus as like a political
rival
actually had him killed
now what ended up happening after that
so caligula goes to live
with her mom with his mom
now agrippina apparently he was
caligula's mom
she um wasn't real shy
about openly blaming tiberius for
poisoning
uh her husband bad idea it was yeah she
should have kept her butt [ __ ]
you know i admire her balls though yeah
i mean for her to like say because she
had to know that that [ __ ] was not gonna
fly you know what i'm saying and and
not much brains yeah i'd have kept my
mouth shut if i suspected that
because yeah now you're casting
dispersions on a [ __ ] reigning
emperor that's [ __ ] a death sentence
yeah it could be that that's not what
happened it could be that's just what
historians
say it may not be true
you know what i mean because you'd think
she had a little bit better a little bit
more intelligence than that
being like but then again murder fest
hadn't really gotten into full swing at
this point
this was early days this is the early
days of it
where it was just a part of culture to
murder people
and here's another thing is it was a
part of court culture to murder people
um i think it was i think it was julius
himself
which is his granddad they had a [ __ ]
kind of like game rich
kids would do they'd go down into the
poorer part of the neighborhoods and
dress up like a poor person
and go around mug and kill people just
for the fun they didn't even need the
money
that's right and they had a [ __ ] word
for it's been a long time there was like
it was like
jacking you know it was like it was it
was the it was the roman equivalent to
jack and people
and and then jack and i think it was i
think it was a i think it was a
teenagers did it like 16 17 year old
boys did it that sounds like some [ __ ]
teenage boys
yeah go out and just go knife if they
could get away with it yeah knife
somebody
you know you need me and they would take
[ __ ] from them but these were rich kids
yeah it's like what are you doing they
were just doing it to get street cred
and i think julius caesar or julius
before he became
caesar uh [ __ ] did that or
or was suspected to have been involved
in that and it was like a fad
that's some [ __ ] huh that yeah it'd be
like that'd be like
one of george bush's sons all right
or it'd be like george bush one right
his son george bush two
back when he was a teenager did a
drive-by imagine that that's it would be
exactly that same equivalent thing is
that when jordan it would not shock me
george bush actually has a teenager
went down and went down to [ __ ] went
down to [ __ ] territory in
l.a and [ __ ] was did some drive-bys
just to be like a badass yeah so you
could so he could so he could vibe with
rap music
[Laughter]
that's like that that's like i said that
sounds like some [ __ ] they would do it's
like that doesn't really shock me all
that much because
yeah well roman aristocrat teenage boys
with money are the worst
another another another thing that
[ __ ] um
roman aristocratic females you know
in their teens and early 20s would go
and turn tricks for fun
pretend to be a prostitute i can see
that
i mean you're not hurting anybody yeah
you're just going out and getting some
strength yeah
you know what i mean these are these are
patrician girls though right but i get
it
and it wasn't sex it was turning tricks
yeah
that was the whole [ __ ] uh well yeah
that was the whole [ __ ]
uh it's just yeah it's just like you're
kind of you're going down slumming you
know
yeah well because you have to think that
their lives maybe were like really
restrictive
yeah and they couldn't just like run
around and do whatever they wanted so
like hey
patricia women i'm just gonna go be a
hoe for a day yeah because you kind of
charge money but like i said i can
understand that yeah you're not hurting
anybody yeah
alex said in my old age i'm partial to
gathering the old gang together and
going out for some muggings
yeah right that does sound really fun
right now
yeah but yeah so other than so agropina
like basically saying
um you know openly accusing tiberius of
killing germanicus
also um tiberius because i guess he
could do this
um would not allow agrippina to
remarry because they're like hey if she
gets married again then
her husband will also be a political
rival and have to bump him off as well
so he just thought it would be easier to
just not let her get married again and
like i said i guess he could probably do
that
so um at some stage so so their
relationship has deteriorated as you can
see
so agrippina and uh one of caligula's
brothers
nero they get banished like they get
charged with treason and then they get
uh
banished so at this point caligula who
was a teenager
um he goes to live with tiberius's mom
livia and then she died and then he goes
to live with his grandmother
antonia minor now his other brother
about a year or two later drusis
he was also charged with treason and he
was put in
uh prison and nero
the other brother he not emperor nero
this is a different person
um his brother nero was also um
they exiled him and he died
they think it was either he committed
suicide by starving himself to death or
they
put him somewhere and starved him to
death he starved to death
is what i'm saying i think he was
starved to death because later on uncle
uncle [ __ ] what was his name uncle
claudius
yeah the one i think it was uncle claude
yeah uncle claudius i think the name was
this thing was he was he had imprisoned
a lot of
what uh caligulous family members and
starved them to death in prison
yeah we'll see we'll see let's see if
they talk about it in here i might be
getting some people confused though
yeah roman history is very um a lot of
the names sound real
labyrinthine yeah and well and a lot of
them have the same names too like i said
because you know caligula had a brother
named nero it wasn't that nero
i read i read gibbons decline and fall
of the roman empire not the little
abridged one
the part one and two they're [ __ ]
huge they're like a thousand pages each
one
most boring read [ __ ] ever and it's
very
detailed and it's a very very repetitive
and with it's funny you read these
historic
you read about history and people in
history and they're all
very ineffective you go okay maybe this
guy will make a difference like oh no he
didn't make a difference
and then another then the lives are very
similar yeah
you know you think well okay well maybe
this guy might change something oh no
i guess not you know yeah
and it's just like just repeating itself
over and over and over again you know
and uh that's it that book talks about a
lot of people who aren't that important
and what's funny is like when you step
back
and you look at all the history any one
person isn't all that important
there's not they're not as important as
you think they are the julia claudians
actually have the most interesting
stories in
roman history and we're talking about
them right now yeah
outside this it gets kind of samey and
samey and samey and samey
yeah yeah that's true so yeah so at this
stage like claudius or uh caligula
rather
um it's him and his three sisters
because like i said his his mom and his
brothers have been
exiled and died um so basically
caligula and his sisters are kind of
stuck under like tiberius's watch they
just like keep them
you know it's in like a palace and [ __ ]
but they just like keep them under guard
all the time
so then in 31ad
um caligula is sent to
stay with tiberius in his little castle
thing
on the island of capri now
caligula ended up staying there for six
years the weird thing and a lot of
historians are like why
didn't because it seemed like tiberius
was real like head up to
get rid of caligula's like whole family
you know what i mean like he was
charging with trees and exiling them
starving them to death
what not but for some reason he wanted
to keep caligula with him
yeah tiberius is the one i was thinking
of that was uncle tiberius yeah
i thought that he had that he had
actually starved a lot of caligulous
[ __ ] family members in prison
yeah two or three of them including his
mom i think it was i think his mom
started death
yeah and then he evidently he told him
later
i saw i starved all your family this
[ __ ] tiberius was a trip he was
a pedo
and he was a terrible terrible person
the island of capri was the original
child
island all right it was he had little
children running around dressed like
nymphs and [ __ ] pants with little
goat feet
and he had them frolicking around and he
you could have sex with them anytime you
wanted to and they were having sex with
each other
he had a bunch of these little boys and
a little in his swimming pool he called
him
his little fishes and he'd [ __ ]
molest them and he had a thing where he
want he liked them to like swim
in between his legs and like nibble at
his balls yeah
yeah and then if if is that nice if the
kid got out of line he'd [ __ ]
take him and have all the kids with him
and he'd take him off there's a cliff
right there by the
swim pool he's still there throw their
ass off the [ __ ] cliff yep
yeah in front of all the kids says
that's what happens if you piss me off
yeah basically they're just flinging
people off cliffs yeah
and if you got some in there you knew
you were like in deep [ __ ] because you
were probably going to get thrown off
the [ __ ] cliff and then they just
scrape your carcass off the
rocks at the bottom so uncle tiberius
was the original child island man
yeah i suppose it was and he was and he
was roundly loathed yeah
he just lived he ran the entire he ran
the roman empire
from that island he never went to the
[ __ ]
on the into rome he stayed right there
in that island yeah kind of like a
[ __ ] crazy ass
crazy ass old man he was an old man at
this period
and here's the thing most people think
that caligula was one of them little
fishes
he was he was a swimming pool fish it's
possible sure i believe he was
i mean yeah like or he was in charge of
the swimming pool fish
so calligra is in this pretty damn
abusive environment that he's
he's his uncle's trapped him molesting
him
his uncle's [ __ ] raping all these
kids and killing him and throwing them
off the damn cliff and has killed
several members of his family killed his
family
his mom his two brothers got him all
trapped as you you know so this
motherfucker's a monster he's like
somebody he's like something out of star
wars
yeah it's like not even yeah if you
wrote him as a villain people would be
like yeah let's tone that down
that's what you're doing but no it's
like you really didn't do that some
serial killer [ __ ]
yeah exactly yeah exactly so yeah so
caligulas lives with this lunatic
for six years now caligula um
was no dummy and he basically even
though
i'm assuming that he totally hated
tiberius because of the whole you know
you killed my entire family and maybe
are molesting me and all this other kind
of [ __ ]
he kind of figured out very early on
know what i'm just gonna keep my head
down i'm gonna keep my mouth shut i'm
not gonna say anything to him about it
i'm gonna keep my ass alive
um so he really didn't like ever call
tiberius out for any of the [ __ ] that he
had done and he just kind of went along
with whatever
now some people have said maybe it was
just because
caligula was into the same kind of [ __ ]
that
tiberius was into and he was just kind
of like whatever where he
pretended that he had he probably
pretended yeah so nobody knows if he was
pretending to be into it or if he
you know just so to keep his ass from
getting killed or if he
actually was really into it yeah now
here's the weird thing
technically what [ __ ] tiberius is
doing would have been legal
under roman law these little kids are
slaves yeah you could buy a child
yeah you could do whatever you wanted
yeah because it was your property yeah
and under at certain times in roman
history and i believe it at this time in
roman history
you had the power of life and death over
a slave that changes later on if i
remember correctly
you couldn't arbitrarily kill a slave
eventually
i think at certain times in roman
history the slave was almost kind of
like a
minimum wage employee i think they had
certain rights
but there was there was some reformation
that went on and this is we're talking a
couple hundred years later
but um even in tiberias's day
the people who are writing this and
commenting about it said that that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] horrible it was not it was
not a been socially approved bond
well no like i said you weren't supposed
to be buying slaves and killing them
yeah especially children you just you
know what i mean you're
they're supposed to be property but they
were also supposed to be under your
protection
yeah so you were supposed to be daddy
as a slave master just be taking care of
these people
that was the that was the thinking
because back and
it made sense because back in back back
when slavery started in greece and
that's really who they're copying
slavery was not a permanent status it's
like a temporary status if you
the greek city-states would fight each
other and if a soldier got captured by
an enemy city
they didn't kill him like they would
back in the old days they'd just take
him back to their city and you had to
stay there for a certain amount of time
usually five to six seven years
and work in that city rebuild it or
whatever
and you know there's all kinds of
accounts that under that old slave
system in in
in greece the slave got
his birthday and uh certain holidays off
where he could go back home
walk back to his city and be with his
family his family could visit him so it
was
greek slavery was an improvement over
what they used to do you know they used
to just kill all
enemy soldiers that were captured but
you know that
that didn't work out in greece greece
tried to make it more humane
so that's really where this comes from
the romans were out there capturing
people and captives of war they take
them back to their
cities and make them work instead of
killing them on the spot
and you know china was doing that just
kill them all on the spot they would
kill they would kill an entire
surrendered army
thousands of dudes just [ __ ] cut
their heads off
that ends up working against you in the
long run yeah
it's better to try to convert them over
to your side
and that's really what the what the
greeks were and tried to do
and in some ways the romans were trying
to do that too they were trying to get
gauls
and germans to join the roman empire
they did
you know over time gauls would
gals would first be like in arena games
and be kind of portrayed as kind of like
ferocious barbarians
but you know a couple decades later
you'd see that they would stop that
and then all of a sudden the gauls were
being portrayed as loyal romans
and patriots yeah you know what i mean
so
romans had had a concept of pc it was
just it was it was a different way of
doing it
you didn't want to sit down there and
bash on on an old
rival forever you wanted to merge with
them
yeah that's what they would do so but
anyway getting back to what i was saying
even
what tiberius was doing with these
little kids on this
on the child island was not acceptable
even for an emperor
or especially for an emperor even back
in those times you know what i mean
that yeah people were just like what the
[ __ ] people were horrified yeah
he's getting away with something that
was legal but they didn't like it yeah
and it's i mean not only that like the
molesting and everything like that it
was just that
he seemed very like capricious in
i mean you just did like a little thing
to piss him off and he's like boop over
the cliff
yeah you didn't get trials you didn't
get anything like that it was just kind
of like
you know if you displeased him he was
just gonna throw you off the cliff and
there wasn't anything you could do about
it
and so people were i mean afraid of him
because it's like you never knew
like if you were gonna be on the wrong
end of his wrath and he was gonna like
summon you to capri and you were [ __ ]
you know
yeah and nobody likes that nobody likes
to have to live under that kind of
fear you know romans knew about greek
pedestrian
which is you know they had ritualized
[ __ ] pedophilia in
in ancient rome the greeks knew about
excuse me the romans knew about it but
uh that wasn't evidently a part of that
was not a part of roman culture
so you know grown men weren't supposed
to be going around [ __ ] little boys
yeah or having them nibble on their bums
under the water that was unacceptable
yes yeah so uh
yeah so apparently so caligula like i
said he knows
enough to like keep his [ __ ] mouth
shut to keep himself from getting thrown
over the cliff
a very famous quote about uh this whole
situation
between caligula and tiberius was never
was there a better servant or a worse
master so but caligula would just do
anything that tiberius
uh said now caligula did actually say so
i'm guessing he wasn't just going along
with it uh
you know or he or that he was just going
along with it just to keep his eyes from
getting killed
because he did say that he uh thought
about
uh killing tiberius and actually kind of
had made some plans to do it but then
like never went through with it
so um but at this point too i mean
and we if we get into this a lot on our
serial killer shows
it's like because some of these people
have horrible childhoods caligula
had a horrible childhood i mean after
his uh
dad died you know he was treated
horribly it's like he was in a horrible
environment he was around horrible
people that were doing horrible things
so you can see how he turned out the way
he turned out you know what i'm saying
it's not really all that surprising and
i'm not saying that you should like
sympathize with them because i don't
think you should but
um you know it's it's just like a
perfect storm of [ __ ] and it really
seems like
tiberius um it's almost kind of like he
wanted to make
caligula like that you know what i mean
like just because
because he didn't kill him he killed
like most of the rest of the family yeah
he's trying to turn him to the dark side
yeah that's basically he was doing some
palpatine [ __ ] that's like what he was
trying to do i mean basically and
there's another famous quote where he
says something like i'm basically i'm
rearing a viper
yeah for the roman people like it or the
breast of the roman people or whatever
i'm like i'm raising somebody to like
[ __ ] everybody over
yeah well he had like a co-ruler he
gave basically handed the empire over to
uh caligula and then a co-ruler what was
his name
which i think was some kind of he was a
cousin
um there was one guy that was like a
there was like a friend of his friend of
his and
i think he made him both co-rulers of
the empire and tiberius says
one will eventually kill the other yeah
the strongest
i guess yeah yeah and he and he's like
they're they're both vipers
one has to kill the other and we'll see
the strongest one will rule
and that's just straight out of [ __ ]
darth vader [ __ ] that's straight out
of emperor palpatine that's what i mean
that's the palpatine [ __ ] right there
that's what tiberius was doing yep
that's probably where they got the idea
from yeah so um
so caligula he gets like an honorary uh
position like in 33
um you know with with the you know
caveat that he would eventually like uh
rise to emperor even though him and
tiberius weren't
it wasn't like a direct succession but
he was you know
just kind of his so he was like he's
next chosen in line
so um at this stage uh caligula's mom
uh who was still alive but she died in
prison and his other brother
uh drusis also died in prison um
caligula got married
actually in 33 to a woman named
junia claudilla um but
she died in childbirth so they were only
married for a year
now at this stage um he meets this
guy who is a prefect a praetorian
prefect
and his name is macro that's generally
what they call them navies sutorious
macro
a prefect was a kind of like a a sub
president yeah i remembered it
i think yeah it was like a sub president
so yeah sort of
kind of like a vice president yeah
and it seems like the the friendship
between macro and caligula was like kind
of went a long way toward
smoothing [ __ ] over with tiberius
because i guess macro would like put in
a lot of good words for
like saying he was a good dude and
everything like that or you know don't
hurt him or whatever
so there was kind of a lot of that kind
of [ __ ] going on too
so uh 35 caligula gets named
uh the joint heir to tiberius's state
along with
uh tiberius gameless who is the other
guy that i think you were talking about
now tiberius finally kicks the [ __ ]
bucket
in 37 a.d yeah they probably killed you
um
you know what it's like some people have
said that because like i said anytime
any like powerful roman died somebody
like [ __ ] murdered him
um they don't they're not sure if he was
murdered or if he just died of old age
or whatever
but some stories have caligula doing it
yeah like smothering him with a pillar
or something like that in the [ __ ]
imperial ring and slipping it on his own
finger and then the head said no you
can't do that
you have a co-ruler but like i said you
know
there's a bunch of different stories and
a bunch of different versions of roman
history depends on who's writing it
yeah and like i said the dude i mean
tiberius was pretty old
so i think most contemporary sources
just said he died of old age
there was really no inkling that um that
caligula had done
it until like later histories you know
what i'm saying so i think they might
have added that like in hindsight in
roman imperial culture though
being too old to defend yourself is the
same as dying and old
okay that [ __ ] is too old to defend
himself he died at old age
[Laughter]
he couldn't fight me
[Laughter]
that was the thinking of the time but
the thing about tiberius though was when
he died everyone was like
good you know what i mean because he was
such nobody liked it nobody liked
cyberius nobody nobody know me
now the interesting thing about this
yeah so tiberius was 77
but i must say that tiberius was an
excellent ruler uh he evidently [ __ ]
managed to the empire very well its
finances were in straight were in very
good shape
they said he was a very efficient ruler
he was a [ __ ] pervert though
yeah he was a monster yeah but see that
just goes to show people he spent all of
his time
hiding not hiding away on his child
island away from all those prying eyes
he sat up there [ __ ] like the damn
emperor from [ __ ] star wars [ __ ]
breeding the next generation of sith
yeah yeah nasty [ __ ] yeah he was
and this is by all accounts he was a
nasty [ __ ] so that part couldn't have
been fake news
well yeah i'm saying that that some of
this [ __ ] because i think some of the
more popular histories that a lot of
people know about caligula from
were actually written like a hundred
years or so like after he was dead
um not that many histories were written
of him while he was still alive but the
ones that did
um you know they said yeah he's a piece
of [ __ ] but a lot of the stuff about
like the incest with his sister and all
that stuff that's like added leader
yeah um so a lot of i don't think that
happened i don't think so either like a
lot of [ __ ] that um
that people know about him now that was
from like [ __ ] that happened like way
after he died know
he was just kind of he didn't know his
sister if i remember correctly
and they did seem to like protect each
other but i don't think well they were
very very close
him and well he had three sisters but
like one in particular yeah their family
been wiped out by that madman and i
think they were the last vestiges of the
[ __ ]
family they came from so they tried to
stick together yeah i i'm not gonna say
that he was
having sex with her i just don't i don't
think that was going on well like i said
the contemporary um
contemporary things that were written at
the time that he was alive
um never really hinted at that yeah um
even though that some other people that
they thought were engaging in incest
like over here they're like though they
said that but it's like nobody said
anything about calligraphy and his
sister so i think that was a later
edition
yeah i'm not saying that makes him an
okay dude i'm just saying that that's
probably
not really into it they're reading into
them too much yeah yeah trying to vilify
them too much
yeah so basically so like i said we were
talking about when tiberius died
um you know some report said that macro
smothered him with the pillow
um you know some said that [ __ ] that
caligula did it probably he just died of
old age
um but everybody was super excited uh
that tiberius had died because everyone
thought he sucked
so basically uh [ __ ] passes to
caligula now the roman people
you know which you know now knowing what
we know now they're like wow it seems
really dumb
but the roman people were super excited
that caligula was gonna be
the emperor he was really young he was
only like in his 20s
um they were really excited that he was
going to be the emperor not only because
tiberius had sucked so bad and they're
just like well how could this kid be any
worse but also because
um caligula his dad was germanicus and
everybody had loved germanicus
so they just figured hey it's like a
young germanicus gay
it's like everything's gonna be cool and
the interesting thing is that for the
first six
seven months of his role everything was
cool like everybody loved the dude
like he would go out like a parade and
everybody would be like yay
he's a star he's this that and the other
thing it was like this really it was a
love fest
you know what i mean which is just very
funny but like considering like what
happened later
but he was actually for the first six
months of his uh reign he was actually
very very
popular i think it made sense the way it
happened
well they did i mean people didn't know
and like i said tiberius you know
tiberius had been so
horrible and everyone hated him and
everyone had loved germanicus
who was caligula's dad so they had every
right to think
right that you know he's going to be
like germanicus because that was his
father
you're right well there's there's a big
difference in the upbringing and the
quality
of the man um but
i think i think i think you know when
they when he was getting all that
fanfare i think he was appreciative
about it at first but then i just
started getting getting to him like
[ __ ] these people man they didn't help
me when i was out on child island
you know what i mean it's like yeah it's
i think i think it was
some of that was cool it's hard to say
because
the timeline is usually like the first
six months of his role like he was super
super popular and you know they
sacrificed animals all in his honor and
all this other stuff
and he was all drinking it up and
everything and then there was like a
then he like got real sick they don't
really know like what the illness was
um caused some brain damage and yeah so
but they don't know because there are
some accounts that even when
caligula was living with tiberius when
tiberius was still alive
that caligula was just as cruel and
sadistic as tiberius was
but that might have been just because he
was going along with it
you know to keep from getting thrown off
the cliff
but some people said well maybe that was
just in him to enjoy that kind of stuff
too so maybe it wasn't that much of
like a hard left turn like when he got
sick and then he came out and he's like
oh suddenly i'm a tyrant well he gets
off on he gets off the island which is
like prison
yeah and uh now he's dealing now he's
basically
in charge or co-ruling a [ __ ]
dictatorship where he has the power of
life and death over people really
and they didn't they couldn't help him
while he was on the island and this is
kind of
he might have seen this as like now it's
time for some [ __ ] payback
yeah you know you [ __ ] are worthless
you know what i'm gonna show you guys
you know it's
it's like vengeance yeah and
according to tiberius that's what he
wanted he was trying to make vipers
and you know we don't know what happened
like it did say that he felt sick
and then when he got better he would he
was worse his demeanor had changed
yeah there's no telling what had
happened maybe he
maybe somebody had poisoned him maybe he
thought somebody poisoned him
yeah that's king that's kind of the
prevailing they're like it could be a
lot of things but
he had some kind of a [ __ ] virus that
attacked his brain
that could be awesome um or it might
have been something as
something as simple as roman medicine
yeah romans did weird [ __ ] they didn't
really have a good idea of [ __ ]
medicine they had
they had access to lead they liked the
way lead tasted
they they ate off of lead plates
delicious they had a lot of lead they
had a lot of lead piping and houses
and you know i had this theory we talked
about it before on the
show back in the 70s 60s 70s and 80s
there was like a [ __ ] spike in weird
ass [ __ ] perversion and
violence in the united states i think it
had a lot to do with [ __ ] leaded
gasoline
yeah you know cars blowing [ __ ] lead
particles out of tailpipes it's
collecting up inside the cities
they got rid of that lead to gasoline
and they quietly got rid of that
leaded gasoline well we don't need
leaded gasoline anymore yeah you know
that they
had to have known that the effects of
lead breathing in lead particles that
couldn't be good
yeah you know which you'd have
heightened [ __ ]
you could have like insanity basically
you know heightened aggression
yeah romans did [ __ ] that was insane
you know there's a lot of accounts of
[ __ ] insanity you know what are they
talking about
are they are they powdering up lead and
sprinkling on food as a flavor
enhancement
because they liked how it tasted yeah
they might do that not even mentioning
it
thinking that there's no problem right
well it was in a lot of cosmetics
stuff like that too and so you might you
know have street vendors that sell
powdered lead in little
little glass bottles hey man drop this
in your [ __ ]
in your coffee in the morning or
whatever i know
drop this in your wine and [ __ ] sling
it down it'll [ __ ] give you a hard on
all day
you know he might have [ __ ] got
something like that goes oh that sounds
like a good idea
i like how the lead and you know so you
might have just taken that for a couple
days and you get [ __ ] cute lead
poisoning man
yeah go crazy it takes for a while to
get that out of your system
yeah so there's no telling what happened
yeah something like that happened though
to him
and when he came out he was mean yeah
brain damage because like i said
like i said it's hard to say because he
did like indulge in some [ __ ] but
with tiberius but we don't know if that
happened under tiberius's
thing if he would have done that [ __ ]
like on his own later if that kind of
[ __ ] hadn't like happened
you know he swore that he had some
seizures too
and when he woke up he was hearing
voices
so well i have seen some historians say
that it could have been
temporal lobe epilepsy um but it could
have been a lot of things they don't
really know
what this illness was romans also took
drugs
yeah uh we don't know what drugs they
are we just know the words that they
used have been a long time since i've
heard them they use certain words for
something that they were taking and they
we have receipts that they were buying
it for parties
yeah and and and very vague references
is that it was
something that made parties go along
better
it was like like an intoxicant yeah but
we don't know what it is
right what are they talking about you
know is this uh is this morphine
is this is this weed is this uh some
kind of a cocaine
based drug we don't know about you know
what is it yeah yeah you don't know
and that's what i mean it's that's why
it's kind of hard to like pin down
because you don't know what the [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] they were getting up to
back then yeah you know what i mean they
had access to a lot of stuff
yeah it's a loss to history yep
but yeah so uh first like i said first
six or seven months he said everybody
loves him
like seriously everybody like that was
kind of like the thing it's like
everyone just adored him and thought he
was awesome
um and he did a bunch of really popular
[ __ ]
like when he first got in like he gave
um
like the praetorian guards the military
and stuff he gave them all bonuses
um he said look these are all tiberius's
like um
you know trees and papers these are all
the people that he said [ __ ] him over
and was like
we're not gonna do that anymore i'm
gonna destroy him it's like we're not
gonna do these trees and trials anymore
like tiberius got known for that
everybody hated so much
so he said okay we're gonna get rid of
all that um you know it's like people
that had been exiled he brought them
back
um he and also he started throwing like
big huge parties for everybody he would
have like all these gladiatorial games
and he would have like [ __ ]
just all kind of like big feasts and all
this stuff so he was like
the fun emperor so everybody was like
yay he was just like this young fun guy
and he was not a dick like tiberius so
everyone was like super happy about it
so then though the good times came
screeching to a halt
in the fall of 37 a.d
now as we mentioned caligula got really
really sick
um no one knows what it is he may have
very well been poisoned or it could have
been some other kind of illness
um he was out of commission for i
believe about a month
so it wasn't like a real you know he but
he was kind of out of the public eye for
a month
victor garcia said that powdered lead is
great on pickles
the wrong ones knew that imagine all the
pickles were wrong it just that just
reminded me of
that old guy that you knew that like
cooked uh fried chicken and motor oil
yeah for those of you guys that don't
know that story
i worked with a guy he's a he's an old
guy
and back like in the 30s he was anxious
he was ancient in the 90s
back in the 30s he would deep fry
[ __ ] turkeys and chickens in [ __ ]
motor oil yeah
and i was like [ __ ] you talking about
man and he's oh yeah it was good
it did remember what his name was it's
not the same motor oil you're thinking
of though
yeah has a lot of additives well it has
a bunch of [ __ ] in it a lot of stuff
clean it cleaners but old school
oil motor oil it was just petroleum oil
it came out of the ground
they'd put it in their hair like pomade
same thing with gasoline they'd use
gasoline to [ __ ] clean their clothes
and [ __ ] yeah
i've seen some like palm yeah like i
said there's there's a short they
actually uh rifted on mystery science
theater or rip tracks
with uh it was like a safety short yeah
from the
30s or 40s or something like that
telling you to like be careful when
you're like using gasoline to like clean
all your clothes you don't
set yourself on fire and burn your
[ __ ] house down i'm like duh said
they'd buy motor oil
you could get old shell motor oil for
[ __ ] you know cheap back then you get
a big old pot of it
and heat it up it wouldn't boil at all
you know just it wouldn't even smoke
because you could get it real hot before
it would smoke yeah and you could take a
battered chicken
whole and just [ __ ] fry it he said
when it came out there was just the
moistest
tender most crispiest fried chicken you
could ever imagine
because that motor oil that hot motor
oil was too thick
to penetrate even the [ __ ] batter
really so it just encased it in heat
yeah and it was just like it was like
almost like it would pressure cook it so
it made it like super juicy
it was super juicy and [ __ ] hold all
the [ __ ] moisture in there
it was hot as [ __ ] and [ __ ] cook it
quickly
and he just said it just [ __ ] was
better than any kind of vegetable oil i
was looking at him like he was [ __ ]
crazy
and he's like what don't look at me i
was like snapper
i was like 24 i just yeah i couldn't
believe it he was telling me he's a
motor oil
yeah it was good you know
yeah okay it took me a while to
understand what it was he was talking
about
10 w 40 chicken is good [ __ ] i said this
[ __ ] was [ __ ] great
you could probably find a recipe for it
online nowadays i'm sure somebody
remembers you gotta find that oil
yeah and the oil part doesn't exist yeah
they probably don't make it like that
anymore so like yeah just
pro tip don't use right he's also
talking about your chicken in he also
talked about that they would cook [ __ ]
like castor bean oil
and you could get castor bean oil super
[ __ ] hot
and fry in it and then it was [ __ ]
great castor bean
yeah i've heard that caster oil tasted
bad but maybe i guess he said you could
fry it and it was great
i've heard that too and like it's funny
because all those old like
do old looney tune cartoons and
everything it's like they would always
like give them like castor oil and the
kids would be like no
yeah yeah because wouldn't it it was
supposed to be a laxative right i
thought that was why they gave it to
them yeah relax they're gonna
it's supposed to taste like really
shitty they used it as motor oil yeah
and bombers and stuff during world war
ii yeah
and uh world war one also those world
war one pilots be covered in castor oil
because [ __ ]
rotary engines on the front of the
[ __ ] biplane didn't seal too well so
it was constantly spraying oil
just spraying off spray it all over you
yeah and then you had to fly a plane on
top of all that
yeah yeah yeah the uh the seals were
just leather seals in the [ __ ]
in the engine so you know it just held
the oil in there
long enough you know what i mean you had
long enough so you just fall out of the
sky
long enough you had a [ __ ] gas tank
and an oil tank it went through both of
it
michael shaffer now i know why i always
got the runs after eating my mom's fried
chicken
castor oil yeah yeah i'm pretty sure
that's what that they never said that
straight up in the cartoons but that's
what i always like
that was what the implication was like
it was supposed to make you poop
caster beans yeah um okay so
caligula gets sick like i said nobody
really knows what it was
whether it was poison or just an illness
or whatever so he's out of commission
for like a month
and then suddenly when he comes back out
into the public
he seems to be a very changed man
uh fun emperor is no more
um he's kind of turned into this
brooding
overly anxious kind of like i said he
was he was real gangly and ugly like
before
but now it just seemed like he was just
all like sinister and everything like
that where he wasn't really like that
before
um and he started doing like as soon as
he came out of his little uh
you know illness or whatever he started
doing essentially what everyone had
hated about tiberius
he starts like killing an exile in
people who he doesn't like
like left and right which is like i said
the main thing that people hated about
tiberius that he'd just like snatch you
off the street and throw a [ __ ] cliff
if you did something he didn't like so
caligula started doing essentially the
very same thing
um he even had uh gameless
who was his co-heir uh he had that [ __ ]
killed
um he had him executed and um
which pissed off caligula's grandma who
was also gameless grandma
uh antonia minor i think was her name um
and rumor was well they said that she
committed suicide but
rumor was that maybe caligula had had
her poisoned as well
um he also had a couple of his other
family members including his
father-in-law and his brother-in-law
executed
um he decided to keep his uncle claudius
around though
because he wanted to keep him around as
uh supposedly as a laughingstock so they
could just like keep him around and be
like
he was deformed which not badly
yeah but any kind of deformation was
was like evidence that there was
something wrong with your soul
in terms of as far as the roman was
concerned they they didn't like that
deformity
yeah if you were deformed then it was
some kind of bad luck
that you know something's not right with
you in the gods
you know that's that's yeah the gods
like struck you to see you must suck and
you must have deserved it which that
turned out to be
uh [ __ ] [ __ ] because eventually
claudius
inherits the [ __ ] empire and ends up
with as a good emperor
yeah he was actually one of the more
popular emperors yeah
[ __ ] during the revolution and [ __ ]
the praetorian guards were running
around [ __ ] looking for the looking
for him and he he thought they were
going to kill him
and then [ __ ] when they grabbed him
they said he said what what's going is
you're the emperor now
he's like oh i am you know no [ __ ] okay
all right on the emperor they put his
ass on the throne he was pretty good
alex said didn't they beat up
left-handed people or something i don't
know
i don't know did that did it extend that
far now i do know
even as recently as the early 20th
century
um i have heard or maybe late 19th
century
i have heard of like school children who
were left-handed they would like the
teachers will like beat their left hand
like hey right with your right hand like
a normal person
i have heard of that happening so it was
kind of scene but i think that was more
a biblical thing because like the left
side is supposed to be like bad that's
like what's
i never heard it or something like that
but that is something that i had uh
heard of before i think my grandma said
something to me about it i remember in
school we had a special pair of scissors
with green
hand on it that was for the left-handed
scissors yeah are those yeah
left-handed scissors the lefty scissors
sure yeah weird well i know because my
sister's left-handed yeah
so um that's the only thing i'm not but
i was ambidextrous when i was younger
but i kind of got out of that
but yeah my sister's left-handed when i
was a kid nobody gave a [ __ ] what side
you read
you wrote with well yeah i was saying
those this is like a long time like my
grandmother's time wrote like before
yeah i mean like early 20th century late
19th century
so um now in 38
which was about a year after his after
he recovered from his illness
uh his favorite sister julia drusilla
died um and apparently this is the one
that he supposedly had had like
incestuous relations with although like
i said i
doubt that that's the case um but they
were very close
and he was apparently um inconsolable
like when she died and basically was
like okay well
she's a goddess now so everyone has to
like worship her as a goddess
so he did that kind of thing like
deified her memory
um okay so that same year
though um he decided to do
like i said he did a couple of good
things too like he did
he did essentially like you know florida
has the sunshine laws where you're
supposed to like you know everything's
supposed to be like clear
like all the public record and
everything he did that kind of [ __ ]
because like tiberius
he would have like all the public funds
and the accounts and everything he would
keep that [ __ ] secret
um but caligula like made it all public
so everybody could check it out so they
could see if there was any like
shenanigans going on
um he like got rid of some taxes that
people didn't like
um he had like gymnastic events and
would give out uh prizes
he had like some money with like his uh
face on it and he would like just throw
them
like out out into the crowd and stuff so
he did do some stuff that was like
popular um he also brought back uh
democratic
elections um so the people were like
even though he had kind of started going
back in the tiberius
direction he was still doing [ __ ] that
people were like yeah yeah you know he's
all right
kind of thing because he was still doing
some [ __ ] that they liked
um but you know by the same token people
are just like yeah but he's doing the
[ __ ] where it's like you know nobody's
getting a trial and everybody's getting
charged with treason and then
you know he's just killing him off and
that's not cool
um and although a trial in rome wasn't
[ __ ]
well yeah but it's like it was just a
gang of people yelling at you
it wasn't much to a roman trial yeah
they tried to reform that which i don't
think they ever really did they never
really figured out a court system
that was fair hard to [ __ ]
hard to [ __ ] form any kind of court
system that can't
that is incorruptible i mean even even
the united states you know what i mean
shitty court system well people are
corrupt
and it is very yeah and just like with
anything else like people with money are
going to be able to game the system in a
way that people with that money can't do
you got money and power you have to
worry about that court system that's
what i mean you can basically just do
whatever you want with it it was the
same back then it was even worse
if you didn't have any money they
basically just hauled you out to the
courtyard that's why it's called court
and they'd [ __ ]
this man has accused the [ __ ] murder
is he guilty uh
yeah yeah he's guilty yeah yeah he's
guilty yeah yeah yeah
he looks guilty look at him look at him
look at him with that club phone yeah
look at him
of course he's guilty do we have any
witnesses
no yeah he's guilty whatever
yeah it's lunchtime but yeah pretty much
that's that's kind of the way it was
does he have any money no okay
all right he did have prosecutors people
that would
[ __ ] fight for the government on
behalf of the [ __ ] state and then you
had defenders you know
so they had all that but it was
just a [ __ ] exercise and who can
who you know of who could [ __ ] spin
the [ __ ] better tail
really yeah you know there wasn't
anything like
evidence you know you might have some
witness testimony
and we know witness testimony hey [ __ ]
it's easy to fake witness testimony and
people lie
and or they you can buy a [ __ ]
professional witness
well and so and some people's um and
some people don't even like mean to
be a bad witness they just remember
stuff yeah they don't see the gorilla
right it's like you know human uh human
perception is is notoriously
imperfect so anytime that's the only
evidence you have i'm just kind of like
you know that's why i'm glad that we
have like forensic science nowadays but
like back then
you can fake forensic science too well
yeah i know but spoil it
i know that but it's like it's harder
yeah um
a pro a pro professional assassin can
the reason why he's professional
assassin because he knows how to leave a
crime scene
without anything that can be [ __ ]
traced to anybody
well yeah that's you know that's what
you have to understand although
yeah you have to understand what the
[ __ ] investigative techniques are
and yeah [ __ ] how law enforcement
investigation goes
and everything in the [ __ ] crime
scene must foil that
and there are ways yeah but like i said
it's much harder
much harder than just yeah you know
because witness testimony very easy to
manipulate very easy to you know have
people
yeah you could bribe somebody to say
something or like i said some people
just might have
been mistaken they might have seen
somebody that looked liked you when it
wasn't you
and you know [ __ ] like this way to avoid
a murder trial or murder investigation
is to make sure that there's no murder
so all murders are hummus or all
homicides are suicides
so that's how you do it yeah every
homicide make it make it look like a
suicide or
accident yeah when the suicide is the
suicide is always
accidental drug overdose yeah so go
ahead and use your imagination
accidental drug overdose yeah if you got
five guys working together
and some drugs you can make anybody look
like that they died from an accident
yeah yeah yep
scary we're just giving all kind of like
terrible tips to people the guys that
are doing it might have been ex-cops
victor said make it look like a bear
attack no that would be bad
[Laughter]
based on based on [ __ ] evidence left
behind
i'd say i'm just saying this off the top
of my head i don't know any of this or
anything like that
okay even though
[ __ ] timothy asked vanvaccius the guy
from my old unit is probably one of the
best assassins ever [ __ ] known
you can google him all right
a lot of these guys doing this are
ex-cops dirty cops and [ __ ]
dirty pis and mercenaries your five guys
jump on some dude [ __ ] inject him
with a whole bunch of
heroin and then just let it take its
course and then just walk away
yeah there's a it's just there's and
this is happening in other countries
where
the people that ordered it are in places
they're in
in positions of authority there's not
going to be an investigation
yeah no well yeah you're just a druggie
yeah
and you know the people that want this
done are people in power
you know yeah that's how they get rid of
their
how do they get rid of their [ __ ]
competition it's just
when there's a bunch of [ __ ]
mysterious deaths
around certain people of power it's no
mystery
it's no mystery it goes back 2 000 years
to row
same [ __ ] yeah so
uh so like i said so people were like
actually like criticizing him for some
of the [ __ ] even though some of the [ __ ]
that he was very popular
one thing he did though was he turned on
his old friend macro
who they'd been buddy buddy right back
in the tiberius days
well apparently caligula found out that
while he was sick
somebody told him hey macro was chumming
up to
gameless you know the other guy the
co-heir because he's he thought you were
gonna cack
and he was gonna be the next you know uh
emperor so he wanted to like kiss up to
that guy
so basically um caligula told his old
buddy macro
to commit suicide and he did another
thing that he did this is very special
this is another this is another kind of
famous story about caligula
was that apparently while he was sick
because he was so adored
there were like all these uh members of
the praetorian guards like senators and
stuff like that
and they were all like making a big show
about like praying to the gods for him
to get better
and some of the dudes were saying stuff
like you know take me instead or
you know i'll sacrifice myself if only
you'll let our emperor live and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
so then when caligula got better he was
just like well
you said you were gonna do it do it so
basically he made all of them
do this [ __ ] like he made them like get
in the [ __ ] gladiatorial ring he made
like some of them kill themselves
he did all this other kind of stuff i
was like that's what you get for like we
were just wishing you would get better
but
he did get better and then he just like
was a complete douche about it damn
like making him do that kind of [ __ ] now
um so at this stage right around
uh 38 or 39. uh
a financial crisis emerges in rome
it seems like no one's entirely sure if
he is sure if he had actually like
drained
the treasury because he was a very um he
spent a lot of money but
let's put it that way i mean it wasn't
just i mean he spent a lot of money on
his own [ __ ]
you know like he wanted like super fancy
parties and palaces and blah blah
but he also spent a lot of money doing
like popular stuff like you know
putting on gladiatorial games all the
time and like building like rates
he actually built like a big racetrack
like right where the vatican is now
like there's even that obelisk that's in
the middle that was that was from that
i think uh i think he also wanted some
kind of special [ __ ] walkway
built yeah his [ __ ] his [ __ ]
palace
to the like the temple of jupiter or
something typical jupiter so
he could just talk so he could kind of
go up there and do it yeah and evidently
he'd like go up to the [ __ ] statue
jupiter and [ __ ] like he's whispering in
the deer and you're telling jupiter to
shut up
do you remember that that's you over
there yeah and he [ __ ] people were
like [ __ ] appalled you know and he's
saying no i'm god i'm god you know that
kind of [ __ ] to say
yeah that was another thing he wanted
people to yeah basically like he wanted
to be like
god incarnate like yeah he wanted
everybody to treat him in fights with
[ __ ] jupiter
yeah jupiter is father of the gods i
mean we're you're talking about god
yeah from the from the roman god the
father that's exactly
who that is from the roman there's no
difference between god the father from
the bible and god the father in roman
religion it's it's two interpretations
of the [ __ ] same religion
yeah um the idea of the father of all
the gods and then all the gods which are
the angels
and then the demigods that the angels
had with the [ __ ] women
of men yeah and uh that's what they're
talking about
yeah but a lot of people think that
there's a big difference between
the christian and judeo-christian
versions of god
and the roman version the greco-roman
versions of gods no they're the same
religion
it's the same pantheon it's just that
the
the judeo-christian version of the of
that pantheon is like
like the redneck version of it that's
the country
yeah sophisticated city people believed
in jupiter
zeus and jupiter yeah yeah oh i see what
you did there oracle i see you're
back in the funky bad 70s that's an mst
reference
he wrote well servo said he was going to
write a song about the 70s
and the movie they were watching that
day i think it was uh riding with death
was set in the 1970s so he thought so he
had like an afro wig and he had like a
little he looked like peter frampton or
whatever he had a keytar or whatever
and then he started singing the song and
it sounded like a disco song but he sang
about the actual
ad 70 to 79. damn so it was very very
funny
let me get something to drink okay it's
not gonna be alcoholic though i'm just
thirsty
yeah yeah i know it's like i just i
don't even i don't even know if i want
another alcoholic drink because i'm
still so [ __ ] tired from like last
night
we drank so much last night you guys you
don't even know and i just i didn't
really get that much sleep
but yeah so so uh [ __ ] starts going
south because of all the money
that caligula is spending on various
things
so he starts doing [ __ ] like
uh basically manufacturing charges
against people just so he can like
arrest them execute them and take all
their [ __ ] uh he starts doing that
um he also basically cried to
the roman public to lend him money
you know it was basically hey we're poor
we need some [ __ ] uh he
put he piled on like a whole bunch of
new taxes he added like a prostitution
tax
a wedding tax stuff like that um at some
of the gladiatorial shows
he would start um like auctioning off
the
lives of the gladiators that were
fighting or like you know having a
betting thing it's like hey would you
you know get this much of it they die
and all this other kind of stuff so they
were doing that kind of [ __ ]
um he also uh rewrote some [ __ ]
like um i guess if there were wills like
a people that had died and left things
to tiberius
he basically went in there and like
scratched tiberius's name out
and then wrote then wrote
like or whatever the ancient roman
equivalent was it's like with the chisel
he like shows all this stuff out and
then put claudius up above it
he's like yeah all stuff goes to
claudius gave to me
but yeah so he did that kind of [ __ ] um
so he was basically trying to get as
much
money as possible um
he supposedly uh spent almost three
billion
sister seas i guess is the the money
that they used back then
like just in his first like uh in his
first year
so that's yeah we don't know how much
that is that's pretty impressive it
sounds like a lot though because it's
three billion
yeah so that's a lot
um so because i guess tiberius had left
him like a [ __ ] ton of money because
like i said he had a [ __ ] ton of money
and he left it to him and gameless and
obviously gameless got killed so
he got all the [ __ ] um but there has
been some
because like i said i feel like that's
kind of the thing that everybody thinks
about caligula like oh he just like
spent all this money on stupid [ __ ] like
you know building all those boats across
that river so he could like ride his
horse
like back and forth across and all like
the pleasure barges and stuff which they
actually found
like at the bottom like really really
nice two really nice pleasure barges
that
yeah mussolini mussolini had that uh
lake drained and at the bottom of it had
the two damn pleasure barges
they were fine too yeah there was some
really beautiful [ __ ] on there
they had uh heated floors and hot water
yeah yeah hot water in them and they
were like little floating hotels
yeah it was like super fancy yeah one
pulled the other
and um they learned a lot from that
because it had valves valve work and all
kinds of piping
and uh the precision fit and those
valves man was like something you didn't
see until the 1920s i mean they had
[ __ ] good technology
yeah and they had some really cool
investment casting
uh ability they had some [ __ ] statues
of a [ __ ] hand they can ward off the
evil eye and [ __ ] all these statues
and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] was just perfectly preserved
and it just like a photograph looked
like a black and white photograph of a
hand
yeah some of the stuff because like a
lot of it's in museum style and stuff
like that and this stuff is like really
really beautiful and it's like really
really well
at certain times the [ __ ] romans were
just unbeatable at that kind of [ __ ]
they were not dumb man these are [ __ ]
smart people real smart
yeah good technology had they applied it
correctly you would have had an
industrial revolution it's just that
like i said before in an
industries happen because you need labor
saving devices and rome didn't need
labor saving devices they had an excess
population yeah and technology was
expensive
anytime they anytime they came up with
technology they usually applied it to
religion
so you know like steam-powered doors
that would open up at certain times it
clocks
steam the water powered clocks and [ __ ]
like that
yeah special effects yeah
yeah they like special effects religion
was big money you know
and it was religion back then wasn't
like religion you'd know it today it was
it was
what you're talking about is the club
scene yeah you go there to dance and get
[ __ ] drunk and get high and see this
[ __ ] badass show and they'd reenact
stuff and you'd have a great time it's
like the theater
and uh like seeing a movie and going to
a nightclub at the same time
yeah there wasn't any of this boring
church type [ __ ] they didn't really have
that
yeah it was that wouldn't sell it was
fabulous it was fabulous
that she wouldn't sell yeah no one would
go to that no they're like what we just
have to sit in an uncomfortable chair
and like
we gotta pay to listen to this you know
yeah the romans wouldn't
sing these [ __ ] dreary ass songs
there's no there's no [ __ ]
kind of [ __ ] church is this i don't
know
what kind of church has no [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna get some booty today
take them clothes off that's right you
know they were like that
you know just take some drugs there's
another shirt right there what kind of
church is this there's no drugs or
[ __ ]
romans knew what's so old you know it
was well
today religion is all this stuff it's
all serious well that's the
that's because you know there was a
monopoly the
catholic church had a monopoly they
forced it on you but in the roman
days it was a it was an open market kind
of like the united states is you know
sometimes europeans kind of don't
understand what i'm talking about when
i'm talking about religion because
religion in america is a lot like
religion in rome it's not like religion
is in europe
later on when it was a part of
government here it was like a
part of the free market there were all
these competing cults and competing
religions
they still exist here today in the us
and each religion offered a certain
experience that you were paying for
you know [ __ ] scientology offered an
experience that you would pay for they
try to move you up and make a
[ __ ]
a wizard yeah i'm gonna make you a
wizard you're gonna pay to become a
wizard but you're gonna become a wizard
that's what they were doing that in rome
too yeah or you know
also it was a thing like a nightclub or
a [ __ ] fetish club
you know yeah look here here he comes
he's going to slice the [ __ ] cow's
head off
[Laughter]
and a statue moved and cut the [ __ ]
head of a statue bowl off you know what
i mean wow you know they just thought
that was cool [ __ ]
yeah they paid to see it there must have
been a good stage act that went along
with it you probably got high
too yeah it was drinking a big [ __ ]
party sure i know the [ __ ]
temple of bacchus it was all about how
much wine you could drink and they were
taking something else too but we don't
know what it was
yeah so you know they're having a
religious experience religion
[Laughter]
getting so drunk you're [ __ ] seeing
bacchus
was so
you're gonna get some if you could get
it up he was he was the most fun of the
gods
he was the most fun of the guy yeah and
who who knows what the [ __ ] bathroom
arrangers were you probably a slave
little slave boys running around little
buckets
you piss in the bucket go to the next
dude pissing in the bucket
because you think that if you're
drinking all that wine
you wouldn't want to be like leaving the
party to to take a leak
yeah especially if there's a big crowd
yeah so i'd imagine they just brought
the bucket to you
i don't think romans were were
embarrassed of that because uh
their bathrooms were kind of like public
restrooms without any stall doors they
sit there and sit on the [ __ ] toilet
if i could talk to the dude next to him
then somebody wipe their ass with them
with a [ __ ] sponge
wet sponge and then they'd wash the
sponge back off and wipe the next dude's
ass
they're [ __ ] nuts man how can you
imagine just having like these regular
conversations and
like
[Music]
there you go sir have a nice day and
he's [ __ ] washing the [ __ ] sponge
off in the [ __ ] water and [ __ ]
that's nasty [ __ ] but they didn't they
didn't worry about it the romans didn't
worry about it
clearly fecal matter did not upset them
yeah nasty they had a difference they
had a different uh
standards of sanitation i heard that
they they found some old
roman will you get rid of steve no okay
the heads you get ready to throw up yeah
you're making me gag
you're making me gag how much do you tip
in us
an ass wiper i don't know no what we
were saying i was looking at the uh
at the um comments and uh
gwyneth who said she was from western
europe she said she was only 30 years
old
and um she's like they had
discrimination against left-handed
people there's like um
if you were left-handed they're like oh
don't write with your left hand you're
writing like a jew
so i guess that was kind of a widespread
thing and then somebody else came on and
said yeah my uncle went through that
same kind of [ __ ] too
so it's not and it wasn't as long ago as
i thought it was
i thought that it like passed with like
my grandmother's age because i remember
saying something about it what part of
europe was that i don't know she just
said western europe
western europe somewhere you never can't
tell what's going to happen in europe
man they'll tell you some
our european people will they'll tell
you they'll comment in the comment
section they'll say the weirdest [ __ ]
it's like they're talking about a world
from back in the 1300s
i don't remember any discrimination
against a left-handed person
like i said i heard about it but it was
from like people my grandparents age
you know what i mean people my
grandparents age i didn't even hear that
from my grandparents age
yeah well it might have been it might
have had to do with the part of the
country that it was
it might have had to do with a lot of
different things and being left-handed
had nothing to do with jews
never heard anything about that i never
heard that i heard that that it was like
a biblical thing like that was like the
devil side of your body or some [ __ ]
in mississippi like i said that's what i
heard
i think i've mentioned this before on
the show
mississippi you know the version of
mississippi jesus was elvis
and elvis mother was jewish
but the way the way judaism was in
mississippi
may have not be we don't know exactly
what they're talking about maybe she
came from somewhere else or what
they've been found like old artifacts in
the old south
that were from really old churches that
had things like stars of david on them
but we know that that wasn't a jewish
church or wasn't a synagogue it was a
church
churches with stars of david in them
there are certain types of [ __ ] like
southern baptists where
they believed the only way to be a
christian was to be a jew first
that you had to go through a phase of
being a jew and then convert into cr
into chris into christianity into
christianity
so i guess you can say it was like a
stylized judaism
you know what i mean they were big into
this [ __ ] magical [ __ ] like you know
the stars of solomon and you know the
wisdom of solomon and
and everything though so it was old
testament stuff you know so you had to
go through
you had to apply to the old testament
laws first and then
go into the new testament and become a
christian
a real christian that's how they
considered it so we don't know if maybe
maybe elvis was saying that his his mom
came from
a sect that was like that you know we
don't know don't know
yeah but there was never any
anti-semitism as i knew it in in in the
deep south
because the deep south was kind of old
testament
yeah they were into that [ __ ] fire and
brimstone type stuff they're like oh
yeah
yeah we we should've we should follow
those ten commandments i think maybe we
should give up the first porn
[Laughter]
he's like i don't i don't like this one
anyway i can i can make an honest i can
make another one just give up my first
born
[Laughter]
wouldn't shock me yeah yeah so so like i
said even though there's
there's a lot of [ __ ] about caligula
like spending all the money or draining
the treasure or whatever
they're not entirely sure if that's the
case because
it appears that all through the time
that he was emperor which was only four
years
um he was still like minting coins like
with the precious metals and he was
still like paying the guards and ever
like on time and [ __ ]
so they don't know if like all the he
was spending like an
amazingly inordinate amount of money but
some of it might have been
not all of it might have been out of
like the public treasury some of it
might have been like his
own money like the money that um
tiberius had left
him because there wasn't really there
really didn't seem to have been like a
separation between like
your money and like the public's money
you know what i'm saying like it was
just all
your money you could just like do
whatever you wanted with it so they're
not really sure
you know how if he actually did like
drain the treasury or if it allowed it
was uh was his own money
so um right around this time too
there was a uh famine which it didn't
last a really long time
but um it was apparently kind of bad and
um
it might have had something to do with
like kind of this financial crisis that
was going on at the time
um but they also speculate that some
other reasons for it might have been
that caligula was at the time
because he was trying to get a bunch of
money so he was like um seizing a bunch
of
uh you know supplies and things and also
he
um wanted to make that pontoon bridge
that i was talking about so he took like
a whole bunch of grain boats
like for that purpose so the great all
the grain like shipments were like
interrupted
so that might have uh played a part in
the famine as well
because the food wasn't getting to where
it was supposed to because
he needed to make a bridge yeah well i
had a boat
i got [ __ ] food well he's like i have
food what do i care yeah i'll give you
food
he was so rich that he was allegedly
dissolving pearls in his
liquor and drinking i heard a [ __ ] i
don't believe that i don't know if he
can do that
i don't think he can just dissolve a
pearl
or maybe yeah that's like but that's a
thing that
a lot of people say about him like show
how like excessive he was
we must be misunderstanding something
maybe they had a candy
that was called a pearl oh it might have
been sugar or something in a little ball
yeah and you throw it in your wine and
it sweetens your wine
and you tell the rich person that it was
a pearl it's like a bath bead
yeah that's what i'm probably imagining
maybe that's what it is and all the rich
people fell for it they're like oh yeah
it's probably fancy yeah probably not a
[ __ ] pearl that comes out of an
oyster
yeah it's probably a pearl of sugar is
what they're talking about it was some
kind of product they sold to rich people
and sweeten your drink you can flavor it
you know what i mean and then the rich
people are like man it was a pearl
maybe like yeah you paid what you paid
the cost of it like it was a pearl
dumb sucker but it was actually just a
bead of sugar
in it that's like something i'd have
done to them back then
look pearls well yeah then you come back
with some rock candy and tell them it's
a diamond
yeah there you go we're gonna dissolve
some diamonds in your wine
[Laughter]
look at those diamonds rock crystal rock
candy
yeah it looked like a diamond didn't it
yeah
little sugar crystal i made rock candy
yeah when i was a kid
but yeah so uh again now claw now
caligula i keep wanting to say claudius
i don't know why that's not his name
but caligula um did actually do some
like construction projects like i said
he did a lot of [ __ ] for his own self
like with all these [ __ ] lavish
palaces and parties and
silly bridges and [ __ ] like that that he
wanted to do
but he also did some stuff for the
people
ostensibly um he did actually like
finish
uh building the temple of augustus or he
didn't finish building it himself
obviously but he paid to have it done
hired people to have it done
um he had like uh he built like an
amphitheater
um he made the imperial palace bigger he
made
uh he did the construction project on
the uh
he did a couple of uh aqueducts they
built a couple of aqueducts
um which were actually kind of like
considered like a really big engineering
marvel at the time
and as i mentioned earlier he built like
a big ass uh racetrack for like
you know chariot races and all that
other kind of [ __ ] which is actually
pretty much exactly where the vatican is
right now
um and the vatican obelisk is that used
to be at that racetrack
um but yeah so he so he had built like
all these kind of public buildings and
improved roads and [ __ ] like that so he
did do some things
for his subjects i suppose um
you know that kind of [ __ ] now uh as we
were saying before
the [ __ ] that he did with the boat
across the [ __ ]
so he take this isn't 39 that this
happened this is a very famous story
about him
um like i said they're not sure if this
exact story is true but they did they
know that they had that he had at least
two pleasure barges because they found
them like in the 1930s or whatever
but this story they're not entirely sure
if this is
the case or not because there's not
really that much archaeological evidence
about it
but so what he wanted to do was he
wanted to
because i guess somebody had made some
kind of offhand comment
about um you know oh that'll
that'll be the day when you can like
ride a horse across this [ __ ] bay or
whatever it is because it's like two
miles across and he's like
[ __ ] i'm gonna do that so that's that's
how the story goes
so he just wanted to do it out of spite
basically so he got
a story yeah so he got like all these
um he made a pontoon bridge yeah he made
a pontoon bridge it's like and it was
like two miles
but actually more than two miles i think
there's some big festival where
everybody would be watching it while he
while he crossed the bridge yeah right
yeah and he rode his horse across
crosstalk like across apparently several
times it was supposedly like a big
[ __ ]
big deal yeah public thing oh he he used
to do like all kind of crazy [ __ ] like
you know wear women's clothes and all
this well that's not that crazy
cross-dressing
yeah he likes to cross-dress well he he
just liked to do anything that was like
theatrical or outrageous or he just
was that type of person it seems like
like he was always just trying to get
attention
i guess but yeah so
um yeah the so the two ships that he had
built the ones that they actually did
uh find they uh they found them in 1930
at the bottom of lake demi and we uh
mentioned that before
um easily two of the largest uh
ships from that time period um
the smaller ship was actually a temple
like a
to diana yeah yeah so um but it had like
marble floors it had like [ __ ]
like you said it had hot water plumbing
all that kind of [ __ ] yeah i think there
was some evidence along the banks where
there was
another little temple of diana evidently
he was doing human sacrifice out there
which was like illegal under roman law
yeah correctly but evidently
it didn't matter if it was illegal
certain roman elites would [ __ ] do
human sacrifices anyway
yeah and uh man
it all goes back to child island man and
is this weird [ __ ] in these stories are
they all true
you know are there still big [ __ ] are
there still underground
religions with rich and powerful people
doing [ __ ]
ritual pedestrian or human sacrifice you
know it's just it's just rumored
it was happening in roman days and it
was illegal maybe it's still happening
who knows
yeah seems like rich people especially
if they're kind of like born rich and
they're just totally
above the [ __ ] grips of of justice in
other words you know they just
you just can't do anything to them they
all seem to [ __ ]
become very weird and um start doing
[ __ ] like this saddam saddam and his
sons were doing weird [ __ ] like that in
iraq i mean you know
who's to say it's not happening here in
the west
yeah you know people are terrible
yeah it's like absolute power corrupts
absolutely yeah
well like i said if you're if you're
allowed to get away with anything you're
just going to keep like upping that i
mean certain kind of people is just
going to yeah and you might be
upping that ante yeah and you you may
have come from a family where you've
been getting away with [ __ ] since you
were a teenager
and just as you get older you just get
worse and worse yeah you just do
whatever you want to do
bees nest says they didn't have sugar
until the tudor era they did
yeah well they may have had something
that was flavored that they were giving
to people tell them they were dissolving
pearls
you're not going to dissolve a pearl and
wine yeah i just that's what i've had as
i felt like you drop a pearl in there
the pearl's just going to sit there in
the bottom
and then you're just going to choke on
it so it's not a pearl
they may have been dissolving something
little and round but it wasn't a pearl
yeah some kind of little flavor capsule
that they were making
selling flavor crystals yeah
yeah okay so also right around this time
um
the uh relationship between caligula and
the senate
started to go south now nobody knows
exactly what the cause of the beef was
to start with might have had to do with
his spending might have had to do with
something like that
it had been a kind of a thing where the
senate
had kind of gotten used to not
necessarily doing whatever they wanted
but just kind of like
ruling in the absence of an emperor
because tiberius had always been out on
capri
so they didn't usually have to worry
about his ass but then like
you know when caligula came in and then
they had to like deal with an emperor
like face to face again so maybe that
was like causing them some problems
um also tiberius had killed
like a bunch of the senators uh as well
now so caligula he gets mad at them and
he's basically
even though he said that he had
destroyed all of tiberius's like treason
records like
his little [ __ ] list of like people he
didn't like
um caligula apparently had not destroyed
those so he basically went back through
them
and he said hey some of you [ __ ] that
are still on the senate
i think that you um were
like you know doing [ __ ] behind my back
and i don't like it so he thought he
couldn't trust them
so basically he just brought in a whole
new
uh you know trial apparatus and stuff
he's going to try some of them for being
like untrustworthy
um so and he would do he also got off
a lot on like humiliating people
like he wouldn't even necessarily like
he killed a lot of people too but
he really seemed to get his jollies out
of making people do
like degrading things you know what i
mean like he would like
you know oh let's have a meeting with
the senators but he's like i'm gonna be
in my chariot you [ __ ] have to like
run alongside the chariot and like
talk to me and you're like he would make
them do like petty [ __ ] like that
just because it made him laugh like to
make them do something embarrassing
like he was really really into that um
so after this happened so him in the
senate were basically like we're
breaking up and it's like they didn't
really want to talk to each other
anymore
so then there was like some other he
found out that there was like some other
people like you know
planning to like kill his ass like
behind his back like i said now
as shitty as he was if you were like a
roman emperor around this time period
you basically had a target on your back
because anybody with any power i mean
they were just
go like you said they were just gonna
bump you off so you had to be
on your guard like all the time and you
couldn't even trust your own
employees or like the people that were
supposed to guard you and keep you safe
because they might get pissed off and
[ __ ] kill you and that would be
really easy for them to do because
they'd be around you all the time so
they could not trust
anyone yeah the guys who made the
american system in terms of like you
know how long a presidential
term would last they kind of looked at
rome to figure that
well between four to eight years about
how long a roman emperor lasted before
he was knocked off
so you're if you're in there for too
long you're probably eventually going to
be assassinated yeah so let's go ahead
and [ __ ] make the terms
four years and you can be re-elected to
do us
a total of eight which most
most emperors didn't most emperors
didn't last eight years
i think most of them were killed within
three or four yeah caligula only lasted
four years yeah
so that's kind of why they did it that
way yeah and that was to get rid of that
was to kind of
take the pressure off that way you
didn't have to assassinate presidents
you could just wait for their terms to
run up
yeah that's it you know it's like it's
too much trouble too much trouble
assassination causes too much stress on
the leaders
just second let them do their time and
then they're gone well yeah because like
i said um
you know if you are operating this
system like
like this you can't ever trust anyone
because i mean anybody could just like
turn on you at any time even somebody
that was like your best bud or your
family members or anything like that
if they wanted you out of the way they
would just like [ __ ] [ __ ] your head
and no one would do anything about it
so you had to basically you couldn't
relax ever
yeah you were emperor for life but your
life was only gonna be three four years
yeah that's why
it's safe to like do that um all right
so
right around this time too um caligula
starts
doing like uh western expansion
so he actually ended up expanding the
roman empire into
mauritania and was trying to
this is funny too he was trying to get
into um britannia
and i guess they did some kind of thing
i think this was this particular thing
where they all said we're gonna go we're
gonna conquer like parts of britain and
stuff like that haven't been conquered
yet
and so he's he wants to go like
challenge neptune the sea god because it
was you know it was an island or
whatever
so he's going to go up there and do it
so he takes all these soldiers and
everything but then they get up there
and basically he just tells the soldiers
hey
just collect a whole bunch of seashells
in your helmets
and then he comes back home and go look
we have taken that's the spoils of war
because he was like fighting against
neptune or something like that yeah but
that's something that's something that a
lot of people point to and they're
saying oh he was crazy
um i don't know if that's why he did it
if indeed he did it
like i said i think he just really liked
making people do humiliating things i
think it like amused him i don't think
he was
crazy you know what i mean yeah
that's not how you define crazy what
insane yeah he yeah he wasn't like
insane like he didn't know
like he was just like loopy and didn't
know what they may have had
may have had like a political motive you
know that's what i'm saying he had
disdain for the military and had you
know
wanted them to do ridiculous [ __ ] or he
had disdain for generals or he had to
stain for
people in the ruling class yeah so he
just [ __ ] made him do made him look
stupid
yeah he just liked making people look
stupid
basically he basically talked about he's
true so like a lot of the [ __ ] that he
did because another probably the most
famous one
uh story about caligly was that he made
his horse a console
um that is not true he never actually
did that uh
he threatened to do it and it's like
even if he threatened to do it i kind of
have a feeling that it was more like a
joke
like he was at the senate like you know
my horse could do a better job than you
i'm going to make my hair yeah i think
that's basically all it was and then i
just think it got like expanded later on
so like i said i know it makes him sound
crazier to say like oh he made his horse
a [ __ ]
but i don't think he did that and i
don't even think that he meant that
seriously i think he just meant it as an
insult he's trolling yeah and you know
and if you read
[ __ ] history i'm telling you this is
how it goes
civilizations get to the point to where
the leader
is a troll you know look at trump trump
is trolling he trolls he trolls
constantly
it's like something a roman emperor
would do
and i think it's just because
because republics have a half-life and
they all start to become degenerate
eventually
and then they're renewed but they're
usually renewed after the flames of
[ __ ]
armageddon you know renewed i just
thought of logan's run
yeah you know just like i said there
isn't really progress
there's just [ __ ] somebody in that
comment section was saying
i think it was zach you said does
history repeat itself another guy said
he said no history doesn't repeat itself
but it's constantly rhyming
[Laughter]
that's that's accurate it constantly
rhymes it's them same themes over and
over again
yeah there's only so much you can do
and you do [ __ ] and eventually it all
fails and then it comes kind of right
back around again you know
we're in a time of [ __ ] pessimism you
know but eventually
[ __ ] falls apart and then all of a
sudden people pick themselves back up
again and then it starts rebuilding and
then
optimism comes back and it's just part
of the system but
it's not a pleasant system it's not it's
it's not really a system it's
it's more like a force of nature you
know and
uh it's just the way things go and um
yeah it's bad yeah
i mean we tried not to be too political
on [ __ ]
13 o'clock because we want the show to
be open to everybody
uh you know i [ __ ] was in service
[ __ ] with the infantry during the
time that the [ __ ] soviet union
collapsed
and there's a lot of [ __ ] when you
look at the united states there's a lot
of parallels between
collapse of soviet union and what's
happening right now in the united states
and kind of the things that happened in
in the roman republic and the roman
empire
there's a lot of similar themes
it's time for america to come back home
and take care of its own business
we're not going to be a global power
like we thought we were
under that old leadership where there's
[ __ ] damn military bases in every
[ __ ] country and we're
we're the policemen of the world that's
a waste of time it's a waste of time
it's a waste of american money
and uh you're gonna see i already
i already see how it's going how it's
going and a lot of people are not gonna
be happy with what i say
but you're gonna see the troops all come
home and
it'll get a lot better for for people
here in the united states
not having to burden the cost to of
being the [ __ ] policeman of the world
now the people that were behind this and
wanted this to happen are gonna lose a
lot of their power
all right these are global players they
wanted that to happen
they're not gonna be happy about it but
[ __ ] them that's only a couple guys at
the top that wanted it
yeah you know it's just that we do we
can't be out there [ __ ] telling other
people how to run their business
all right get back to the show yeah
because then it's dudes like me that
we're paying for it
you know i'll go ahead yeah i'm just
saying it's like i'm i'm just like
really sleepy so i'm trying to i'm
seeing
i'm trying to get through all this
trying to get through the notes i know
so as i mentioned earlier one thing
that maybe kind of leads me to believe
that uh
that caligula wasn't entirely sane was
that he does seem to have
wanted everyone to treat him as a god
essentially now this wasn't unusual for
emperors that were like
dead they did get like deified to some
extent like after they died but
apparently colleguilly didn't want to
wait that long
um he wanted to be a god while he was
still alive so he would kind of like
come out
in little god outfits like hey today i'm
mercury and today i'm apollo and all
this other stuff
um and i guess in some public documents
from the time period he actually
referred like had himself referred to as
jupiter so he was just kind of like
stepping all over all the gods dicks
and basically saying he was the best
hold on i have to have to have to say
something um
yeah to michael yeah there weren't term
limits until fdr
but the term was four years and that was
uh that was the roman empire
uh uh [ __ ] theory that they were
coming up with is that
yeah maybe you should have as many you
could be elected as many times as
as the people wanted but it shouldn't be
longer than four years
each each election and uh if i remember
correctly
they talked about what the average life
of an emperor was
but okay go ahead yeah um yeah so
apparently they did like a couple of uh
they built a couple temples in rome
where you were supposed to go and
worship caligula
um also the you know the temple of uh
castro and pollux he actually like
he had it like something built onto the
back of it like
he built the imperial residence or
expanded the imperial residence into the
back of it
and then basically dedicated the whole
thing to himself
um he would like take statues of gods
and he would like chip the heads off and
put his own head on there
um you know so that kind of [ __ ] so
that really didn't like i said even
though dead emperors
were deified to some extent this was um
a little bit beyond the pale so a lot of
people thought this was uh
kind of some crazy [ __ ] as well um
there was also like some kind of [ __ ]
where
he kind of got in trouble too with like
the [ __ ] jews the [ __ ] jews no
there was like a there was kind of like
some uprisings and civil wars and stuff
and
he was basically like people would come
to him for help and he would just like
do
like humiliating [ __ ] or like say
humiliating [ __ ] to them or like
like he didn't give a [ __ ] like yeah
whatever i can't help you why don't you
eat pork what's the matter with you it
was like that kind of [ __ ]
he was just like really dismissive and
really didn't seem to give a [ __ ] about
um anybody like he just kind of wanted
to which is like hey i'm decorating my
palace like
don't bother me with that he did he did
[ __ ] up [ __ ] too he'd order somebody
killed right in front of him for
something kind of minor
and then joke around with that person's
family yeah he would do
yeah he would do that yeah yeah killed
him so like i said even though i'm not
i'm you know i'm saying that he wasn't
like
insane you know in the sense that i use
insane in the sense that he didn't know
what he was doing was wrong he was
because he was just like you know
doolally or whatever um i just think
that
he was a narcissistic um
cruel dude who just enjoyed seeing other
people
suffer and only cared about his own
comfort and only cared about his own
self i always kind of imagined him to be
somebody not always but once i heard a
[ __ ] uday hussain
i think he was a guy like uday hussein
yes saddam hussein's
son that's who i i pictured uh
i pitched him to be like that yeah he
did kind of
seem to come across like that like i
said not insane but just like
just a complete sociopath who's just
like i can do whatever
now even apparently like he did marry
again later on and he had a daughter
but you know some of the stories where
he would have like all these big
lavish parties and then like all some of
the
some of the guests that were there like
would be there with their wives and he
would basically just like oh i'm taking
your wife and he would go and [ __ ]
rape her in the other room and then he
would come back out and like
describe like give a blow-by-blow about
what he had done yeah
and [ __ ] like that and the dude just had
to like stay there not
take it because if he said something
like if he lipped off he would like have
him killed
that's like something would do yeah so
he would do that kind of [ __ ] because he
knew he could get away with it
like and apparently too that one thing
he would say to his wife even though she
was supposedly like super hot and
everything because
because of course she was but apparently
he would like lean over and say [ __ ] in
her ear like you know i can have your
throat cut anytime i want to so it was
like he was kind of like he just liked
being able to like
have the power of life and death over
everybody that was just like the kind of
person that he was
so like i said he was just like a
[ __ ] sociopath he got in there by
accident
yeah i mean essentially he wasn't really
like
no he wasn't he wasn't [ __ ] well bred
for the [ __ ] positions of authority
yeah and like i said he was he was young
too like when he got in he was only like
in his early 20s
yeah um you know or 24 i think he's 24
25 something like that
um so so as i said even though some of
the stuff about him
is probably exaggerated i will note
that two very famous historians who were
around at the same time as him so they
you know
shared the same heir that'd be seneca
the younger and philo of alexandria
um they actually said he was insane
uh they said he was short-tempered
self-absorbed killed on a whim and
indulged in too much spending and sex
uh you know and they also said the story
about like he would like sleep with
other
people's wives like in front of them and
then like he would rub it in their faces
um he would just like waste money on
stupid [ __ ]
um you know which kind of caused like a
lot of starvation and famine and [ __ ]
like that
uh he built like a giant [ __ ] bronze
statue of himself and he put it in like
the temple of jerusalem
he did that kind of [ __ ] he was always
kind of like trying to just get in
people's faces because he could you know
because he could get away he got his
eventually though
well yeah we're probably getting to that
don't they all it's kind of like
you can't be a dick for that long
without somebody taking your ass out you
know what i mean eventually
in one way or another um you know so he
would have
like he would have like some
gladiatorial games right
and then he would take like one whole
section of the audience and be like
throw all them in the middle and let the
lions eat them yeah like he would do
that kind of [ __ ] yeah
so like i said a whole section of the
audience yeah it's like oh you're the
lucky ones today
he didn't like how they reacted to
something you know [ __ ] it in there
uh yeah he kind of reminded me of
another emperor's name was golobilis
who's kind of like that yeah i know same
kind of dude is kind of this
bleeding some kind of weird eastern
religion he was worshiping some kind of
a black stone
he to kind of go through this
cross-dressing [ __ ] ritual
with all these kind of weird ambiguous
sexuality people all around him
and he was doing weird [ __ ] with the
petroleum guards and
he had molested some kind of praetorian
guard or dishonored him i don't remember
exactly what it was
but uh they sent up either a wrestler or
a particular guard going there one night
[ __ ] they
choked his ass out and killed him and
then they threw his body
down into the [ __ ] latrine the royal
latrine and it was never retrieved
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] guard said no we
threw his ass down into the [ __ ]
where it where he belonged and it's
going to stay there
and then me emperors went back into that
[ __ ] palace for centuries
living in that [ __ ] palace they never
did get glamorous body out of the shader
yeah everybody kind of hated that he was
another lunatic yeah he's a lunatic he's
a [ __ ] lunatic we should have talked
about him on this show too
yeah about all the lyrics i think
galapagos was trying to copy
caligula yeah some of the [ __ ] they did
a lot of the same [ __ ]
it was later a lot longer long time
after that though
yeah it wasn't well you know maybe a
hundred years later
maybe not that much but yeah i think it
was yeah i don't remember the exact date
it might be close to 100 years later
another guy a lot like that appeared
yeah but yeah see so
so there is some reason to believe that
a lot of the [ __ ] that he did
like you know killing people around like
[ __ ] other men's wives in front of
them and then rubbing their faces in it
that was probably fairly accurate
because that was written by historians
that were around at the same time as him
now all the [ __ ] about um the incest
with the sisters
um him turning the palace into
essentially a whorehouse
him pimping his sisters out um that kind
of stuff
that didn't come about until later
like because suetonius was not um a
contemporary
of caligulas uh or cassie's dio wasn't
either they were
two of the kind of famous ones that
wrote about him but that was later
um so the thing about it is that
unpopular uh government officials
emperors and things like that
that was i mean incest and uh
sexual perversity were kind of two
things that
that kind of went hand in hand with like
you know oh they [ __ ] up all the
governments so they must be like
perverts and they must be like horn
their sisters
so that so it's hard to say if that was
true or not because that was a that was
uh an accusation that got thrown around
at a lot of people that they didn't like
yeah you know [ __ ] here in the united
states during the 20th century maybe
what they do is they say well he was gay
yeah all right but you couldn't say that
in rome because [ __ ] that wasn't
unusual everybody's like yeah
they're like hey what's that it's just
kind of like nowadays because they were
kind of like
kind of a unisex kind of thing where
they were bisexual kinda uh to be
totally heterosexual was considered to
be odd
um although once a guy got to a certain
age he was supposed to be totally hetero
pretty much
that was kind of the traditions that
they had
you're supposed to outgrow any kind of
homosexuality
you're gay face yeah there's like a game
like a [ __ ]
bi phase you know until they were about
30 and then
you're a man now you're not supposed to
be [ __ ] around that [ __ ]
that was kind of the the way the roman
life went but there wasn't any kind of
pejoratives about oh he's gay
it was now
one thing that they could not have is
they could not have a cross dress an
emperor
because an emperor had to be a man he
couldn't be a woman it would be an
emperorus
and the emperor's if he was at emperoris
and that means he could marry a man and
if he married that man he would become
the emperor
so there was no they did not if you were
a cross dress
and emperor you were going to get
[ __ ] killed
because you might marry a man and make
him make him the emperor yeah
they weren't having that even the
pretorians weren't going to have that
victorian guards weren't going to have
that yeah and that was another common
theme
you know what i mean if if the guards
started catching you dressing like a
woman your ass was [ __ ]
your ass your days were [ __ ] numbered
because they were like who's the emperor
gonna be because
the new she she's going to marry some
dude
that's the so you know i mean because
all you have to do
is to become a woman is to put on yes
well they're caught up in that damn
gender identity politics where
where where men can be women
like you have today you know what i mean
where that transgender women are women
that's how they look at it no i'm just
no i'm just saying that
i'm thinking it's funny that like just
putting on women's clothing
would make you you didn't have the
hormones back in rome you just put the
clothes on and now you're a woman
that's just very if you put the clothes
like it's not that simple you put
women's clothes on and you
self-identify as a woman in the roman
mentality like
okay that's a woman we gotta respect it
now who are you gonna marry okay well
then he's the emperor
dan says put on a wig and lipstick and a
skirt transformation completely exactly
exactly don't be don't be don't for one
second
think that you have all this gender
fluidity and all this
permissiveness that machismo goes away
it doesn't go away it's accentuated
now it becomes who's the top and who's
the bottom yeah
all right that game will be played until
until the end of time
it just is and the romans played that
game long ago we already know the rules
yeah so if it goes back to that those
are the rules you're going to get
those are the same rules you have in
[ __ ] maximum security prison oh you
want to be a woman now
well who's your man okay like that you
know
this is gonna be yeah yeah they've
already got it figured out
yeah oh i thought he knocked someone hit
the phone
yeah so uh let's see where was i okay so
basically um because all of this crazy
[ __ ] that he was
doing a lot of the crazy [ __ ] that he
was doing
was actually like directed toward uh
the senate so and also
like the equestrian class the nobles
things like that so
not surprisingly because he was such a
douche um
there were several uh conspiracies
to take him out um you know like i said
it was kind of a thing where
he had to like watch himself all the
time um he basically
i read somewhere that they think that
his palace
had like all the walls were mirrored and
[ __ ] like so he could all like always
see behind him
and like all the hallways were kind of
narrow so like only one person could go
at a time so nobody could like flank him
and [ __ ]
like they so he had all these kind of
like security measures and he had like
some slaves that were supposed to like
guard him and everything
they were supposed to be more loyal than
because they didn't have any thing to
gain from killing him you know what i'm
saying because they were just slaves and
they weren't gonna be anything
more than that so he figured that that
would be
you know that would be better for them
to guard him because they didn't have
any reason to like bump him off
so um so some people did like you know
they had conspiracies to try to kill him
but they were not successful
however eventually they got his ass
yeah now there was a group of guys they
were in the praetorian guard
um apparently the main guy was named uh
cassius
sharia korea i'm not sure i'm not i'm
not up on latin so i don't know
um so they there's three of them planned
it they think
um but they think that a whole bunch of
other people like knew about it or like
yeah do that [ __ ]
but the the three like maine guys they
were the ones that were kind of in on it
so what ended up happening and like
actually kind of pushing him was like
yeah we're going to do this [ __ ]
was that in 40 a.d caligula told the
senate
he's like look um i'm leaving rome and
i'm not coming back
i'm moving to alexandria because i think
they will be more willing
to indulge in my living god cosplay
yeah over there so i'm gonna do that and
go like
drink up on the god worship in
alexandria apparently that's what he
told them
so they were like okay this seems like a
good time to do this because he's
leaving
uh on his little god adventure yeah
let's
like [ __ ] do this so um you know
because him leaving would also kind of
leave like a power vacuum blah blah so
there was like all kind of problems that
would
that would ensue with him like not being
sounds like almost like a de facto
abdication
it did kind of sound like that actually
for him to say he's probably planning
not to come back
[ __ ] rome i'm going to go become a god
[ __ ] off
what's going on there like uh he's got
to go i'm going to go start my own
senate with blow and hookers yeah
exactly
that's essentially what he was yeah what
he was doing and boy
um yeah boy [ __ ] zac knows all about
boy
zack saying i wish i was gay back
trying to soak up all that gender
fluidity well there's all those sexy
gladiators back then
they're sexy little loincloths and
sandwiches all these [ __ ] bisexual
top [ __ ] all
rippling with muscles and [ __ ] trying to
chase zach down those little narrow
hallways
ain't that right yeah okay
he's like i'm ready man
[Laughter]
yeah so so basically like okay well he's
gonna leave this is gonna cause all kind
of problems um you know we're not gonna
be able to stop him from doing whatever
the [ __ ] he wants to do over there and
it's gonna look really bad
so uh if we're gonna kill this [ __ ] we
need to like move on it
so uh apparently that's what it that's
what they decided to do
now one thing too that might have uh and
this is kind of tying back to what you
were uh just saying about the maximum
security prison games
yeah was that cassius was also uh had
personal reasons for not particularly
like liking caligula because caligula
basically
um called him a homo all the time
because he had called me a goddamn homo
because he had like kind of a
i guess he had kind of like a high voice
like a like a feminine voice so it's
like every time he had to tell caligula
something
um he'd be like you wish again he was
like that
you know right yeah so uh after a while
that got really old i guess
so cassie was just like yeah let's kill
the party
he's like i'll teach you to like keep
making fun of my [ __ ] voice you
[ __ ]
which fair enough so uh so yeah he died
like a [ __ ] i'm telling you man
like a [ __ ] i feel like a lot of them
did yeah a lot of them did die like
[ __ ]
they're a bad [ __ ] until that
dagger starts coming down on him and
then they want to try to back up off of
it and it's [ __ ] funny man i watch
some of these [ __ ] channels i've seen
a lot of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] sent to me
from mexico during these
during these cartel wars the bad
[ __ ] will turn to 180 real quick
when he starts seeing
his pieces of his body get cut off
i mean i can understand it but you
shouldn't have got yourself in that
[ __ ] travel in the first place
and sometimes it's hard to have sympathy
for
somebody who's called it on themselves
well that's what i'm saying about
caligula it's like look it's like nobody
he was kind of like tiberius it's like
when he died everybody was like good
yeah nobody's nobody was sad about it
why would you be he was a terrible
person
it was a stone cold [ __ ] murderer he
killed people for next to nothing
and then try to joke around with their
with their [ __ ] yeah he was and not
only that
anybody deserved death it was this dude
i have no [ __ ] sympathy i don't
either
i don't either yeah that's not lucky to
have lived as long as he had
yeah had there been more men in rome
that [ __ ] wouldn't have lasted a
year
yeah okay it's just that they were
scared of him because they
respected convention he was the [ __ ]
emperor so they kind of respected the
office
no [ __ ] all that if you respect the
office of the emperor
murder every bad emperor that occupies
that office
until a good one but the romans couldn't
really think that way
they wanted to think that way but they
were afraid to think that way
but like i said eventually you traipse
around [ __ ] rome acting
up like you did and somebody's gonna
take you out yeah
i mean it just it's gonna happen he was
lucky and it's usually like some of your
own dudes or like somebody that's like
in
your [ __ ] palace most emperors were
murdered by their own
own guards their own praetorian guards
yeah because they're like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah
one of them [ __ ] got one ampere
i forgot which one it was
um the the emperor that killed him was
because he gave that
he gave that guard sexual insult and it
wasn't really
stipulated what what that was did he
rape him
did he insult him in some way about
maybe his dick was small
we don't know but the assassin was a
praetorian guard
who had taken sexual insult yeah
so and you that sounds like rape i mean
[ __ ] the guard knew that it didn't
matter how bad that emperor was you're
gonna be killed for that
if you were caught but he was went out
like a kamikaze he was ready to die
he's like [ __ ] it you and i are that one
either me or you or both of us will die
tonight like that [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
romeo and juliet yeah
we're both dying tonight [ __ ] yeah and
[ __ ] stab his ass with a [ __ ]
gladius yeah yeah so what happens now
what happened
so basically so it's january 22nd
uh or maybe the 24th of 41 a.d
now uh little caligula is going to
uh i guess he'd been to some kind of
theater thing or whatever
and it was like midday which uh was the
time that he usually like to go have his
bath
so he was like going through this
corridor
like towards like his quarters like
where the bath was
and he kind of stopped to talk to i
guess it were like some acrobats or
performers so they were like warming up
or whatever in this like little area
so he stopped to talk to them and uh
then cassius who was with him uh you
know the head conspirator the one with
the
feminine voice he just like leaned in
there and started stabbing
so basically uh the other two guys and
maybe some other people that came by
they just basically just
started stabbing the [ __ ] out of him
they stabbed him at least 30 times
um so the like i said it wasn't just
the three of them there were some other
people as well
um yeah i think some were if i'm
recording some of them were acting as
lookouts
to try to keep people from seeing what
was happening because they'd been
planning on this for a while
yeah it was like a real like the it's
still there like the the hallway
secret passage that was supposed to be
supposed to get from one place to
another they were everywhere all in rome
yeah that way you could get from one
government building to the next without
having to [ __ ] use the surface roads
yeah supposed to save you from
assassination but that's usually where
they assassinated an emperor
down in little well yeah because like i
said it was usually your dudes like
people that worked for you
and could get close to you they'd be
like yeah buddy buddy
yeah so they kind of block off an area
make sure that nobody walk up on you and
secure the area and [ __ ] come in on
you and [ __ ] kill you in private
yeah and that's essentially what
happened like i said they just stabbed
the [ __ ] out of him
uh by the time his guard got there he
was already dead like i said he had been
stabbed at least
30 times um the guard
the the guys that were the guards were
like apparently really upset i don't
know if
like they'd really liked the guy for
whatever reason maybe they were dicks
too i don't know
um so they started like trying to like
attack
the assassins yeah um and
just people that were standing around
well they had all kinds of vows a
loyalty and there's a bunch of
interlocking stuff too to where you
they'd
be killed for [ __ ] dereliction of
duty like standing orders
just because he was a dick doesn't
doesn't mean that they were off the hook
yeah so i don't know exactly what
happened with those particular ones a
lot of times it's not mentioned
sometimes it is mentioned yeah what
happened to the guards was it ever
mentioned
um they basically just said well the
guards like attacked like a bunch of the
people but i don't think they killed
anyone necessarily but some people got
wounded
yeah where the assassins hunted down and
and and murdered
i don't think so it's not mentioned is
it i don't know is it
see it's strange and i think a lot of
times
i noticed that in reading roman
histories is that there'd be like a lack
of information about the assassins
which always led me to believe that they
were hired by other [ __ ]
elites to go do it that they weren't
acting on their own
yeah and the reason why you don't hear
anything about them is because they got
off the hook they were protected
yeah that's what i think happened
because in some cases it did say what
happened to the assassin
yeah and i think in those cases the
assassin acted alone
but in cases where it never really says
what happened to them i don't think they
were acting alone they had state backing
yeah the but of the new emperor well
yeah the families of the new emperor
because i think i mean particularly in
this case like a lot of people wanted
caligula dead
and it's like i think i'm sure it was
all arranged already yeah
they had all that [ __ ] figured out and
they're just like yeah we're gonna do it
and yeah and
i guarantee the dudes that did it were
acting under the orders of the new
emperor that was to come
that's usually logically that's what
what happened yeah that [ __ ] usually
isn't something that's pulled out of the
ass
it's a it's a conspiracy yeah
yeah and thought out yeah so like i said
um one of the documentaries i was
watching they showed the actual
uh corridor like where they think it
actually happened which actually was
underground they didn't find it until
2008 but um it's still it's in real good
shape but they
they showed it and everything there now
after caligula died
um the senate attempted to um
try to restore the republic because like
i said at this stage caligula was only
the third
uh roman emperor so cassius who was one
of the uh
you know the main assassin
he was kind of trying to get the
military like on board with it it's like
you know we want to
you know be a republic again um but the
military didn't want to do that um they
liked the idea of having the monarchy
so basically and this is pretty horrible
too um
basically what happened after that was
that the same assassins
uh that had killed caligula they were
worried that
having any of caligula's family still
alive
um would like maybe another one of them
would
ascend to the throne like someday so
they basically went and they killed his
wife
and they picked up his baby daughter by
her feet and smashed her head
into a wall yeah i remember that point
and killed the baby yeah
so he would have no no you had to do
that yeah
in roman culture had she lived to
adulthood she had plotted against the
[ __ ] assassins eventually and coming
everything was a constant cycle of
retribution if you went after somebody
of power you had to go after the whole
family
and uh they actually did go after
claudius too
who uh you if you remember was uh yeah's
uncle
but he actually got away because there
were some people that were still like on
his side so they helped him get out
um so he actually ended up getting the
support of the praetorian guard
eventually
and uh had an amnesty in bubble right
yeah even though he was kind of made fun
of a lot of people uh if i remember
correctly a lot of people behind the
scenes
liked claudius yeah he was reasonable
you know and he didn't approve of all
these abuses
yeah that's how i wrote and as i said i
mean i you know i didn't read too much
about claudius also all i can remember
is like [ __ ] that i learned in my
history class or like [ __ ] that i've
read over the years but
he definitely does seem to be one of the
better liked yeah
uh emperors yeah i forgot what was wrong
with him he had a club footer
i think it was a club foot yeah which
was enough in rome to where they were
kind of skeptical
but um from my memory i haven't read
about him in a long time you know
my memory once he took power he was
liked
yeah you know people felt safe around he
was he got [ __ ] done
that's kind of the impression that i had
too and he wasn't real
i mean the reason it's sad the reason
that we remember caligula and nero stuff
like that because they were
horrible because they were terrible they
did terrible things and i think we
talked about this a little bit before
maybe when we were talking about i think
it was when we were doing the show about
vlad the impaler
vlad tapish i think that it's kind of
sad but
if you're just like a good ruler you get
[ __ ] done everybody likes you
and stuff like that you know people are
not as
inclined to remember you hundreds of
years later as if you were just a total
and complete
monster just like like hitler you can't
even use that name anymore
yeah because you'll never be forgotten
yeah that's and that's it's sad but i
feel like well human brains i mean
i guess for evolutionary reasons but
we've kind of evolved to pay more
attention to
negative things like because it could
get our ass killed
you know what i mean like back on the
you know on the savannah or whatever
it's like you kind of had to pay
attention to whether there was a [ __ ]
lion over there somebody's going to eat
you
so you didn't want to be like all happy
clappy like [ __ ]
you know and just concentrate on good
[ __ ] all the time and then get your dumb
ass eaten
so you really had to like worry about
negative [ __ ] all the time
so i do feel like that goes a long way
toward like why people are
interested in like true crime like why
why we remember
you know serial killers why we remember
like all these monsters of history but
we don't care as much
about dudes that were like good rulers
that were like good or fair
like you know got a lot of good [ __ ]
done because it's boring
yeah i guess it's not exciting
because you didn't have to live back
then and it probably sucked like living
under this person
yeah but you know but that was claude
that was caligula
yeah and uh yeah people are mentioning
that you know this is kind of relevant
to today
all of roman imperial history all of
roman history is relative to america
uh america today is more like ancient
rome than europe
was is today it's it inherited a system
a lot like that
and a lot of the same excesses a lot of
the same
politics a lot of the same corruption
the same growth and success the same
a lot of it is the same a lot of the
same imperfections
but you know [ __ ] also a lot of the same
excellence you know rome had a lot of
excellence in it too
um it had excellent individuals they
achieved a lot
they were very intelligent you could
take an elite roman
who had an education teach him english
to read and write english teach him our
number system and then give him the
internet he would understand everything
he saw
he would understand everything they had
the ability to grasp anything turbans
jet jet engines you know rockets
computers they'd be able to understand
that
um firearms
energy production even things like
[ __ ]
solar systems and galaxies you know
[ __ ] cosmology they would understand
all that
they uh they had the kind of mind that
could grasp that
and you that couldn't be said for other
ancients
you know what i mean like and they'd
have they'd have a harder time grasping
a lot of the ideas i think
um but a roman could
uh romans considered themselves superior
to everyone basically yeah and there was
something to that
they were superior for a while you know
for a few centuries
eventually you know the rest of the
europeans caught up with them you know
uh where i think the germans
or you know or the non-romans the ones
that started invading the
invading the roman empire and evading
the roman capital
actually were doing it because they
thought they could do it better
and um
you know because the romans themselves
eventually started to stagnate and kind
of fall behind
they stopped innovating then he started
copying germans
what the germans were doing so
yeah they were a superior culture for a
while you know
yeah but if you don't stay on top of the
game you fall behind
and what got him was corruption
corruption and greed
good living even the romans themselves
said they had a corrupt and selfish
ruling class that did things that were
against the interest of the empire for
their own personal gain
well yeah and like i said a certain type
of person that's a very natural thing
i mean you give honestly probably you
give 90 95
of people if you gave them all the money
in the world
and just like all the power they can
just do whatever they want to
i think most of those people would
become monstrous
i don't think there has to be any kind
of like intervening
i think those situation can like make
monsters
the greatness of rome started in the rep
in the republican period
when they were expanding and they were
winning wars and they were doing it on
the back of [ __ ] a real good military
power but then the p the the ruling
class
made promises to these veterans that
they would get
a farms and retirement after 20 years
and
that they could make a living as farmers
but they betrayed them this is after i
think it was called the peloponnesian
wars
things what it was called and um
i may have it wrong had something to do
with the war with carthage
and uh they came back home and they got
[ __ ] they didn't get their farms
instead the rich people in sourced
farm production and labor to slaves that
they owned so
you had a bunch of unemployed veterans
then people didn't want to [ __ ] join
legions in rome so rome slowly started
to
lose reliable military power and that
was the beginning of their kind of
downfall
was uh the economy was not supporting
the military and the military couldn't
fuel the economy
it's because it's all working together
and it never really corrected that
problem and then they never developed
the kind of technology you needed like
telegraphs and trains and
eventually just got swamped and another
thing is is that eventually
roman thinking started to get down into
quagmires where
german christians were [ __ ] faster on
the ball than romans were they they lost
the hedge
yeah the [ __ ] you had you had romans
inside the senate
you know this is later on when
christians german german germanic
christians started to appear
who were barbarians or the romans
considered them barbarians
the [ __ ] the romans were [ __ ] kind
of like
stuck in a damn mental quagmire and
[ __ ] only thinking about themselves
and uh
they weren't open to change or
innovative thinking you know and
german christians were like innovative
in in comparison to them so
you're going to lose the edge you know
you have to stay flexible
you have to adopt new ideas you have to
[ __ ]
be able to [ __ ] you know roll with
the punches and
the roman system couldn't do that yeah
eventually it just it became [ __ ]
senile
it reached civilizational senility
and then it ended up being where it was
just italy you know
there's no and there was no empire
anymore it was everything was some kind
of
visigothic kingdom which was basically
german
trying to take the best things rome had
you know
they were no joke a lot of people forget
forget about the visigoths they were no
[ __ ] joke man
they had beautiful [ __ ] cathedrals
good technology
good [ __ ] steel making um yeah they
were
kind of medieval but they were still
technologically advanced to romans
yeah you know um what you were saying
before about
um uh caligula having seizures
i think that actually came from a bit
later because like i said they
you know they're not really sure they're
only a couple of like contemporary
accounts of him which
you know like i said they call him
insane but they're not really sure if
they mean
insane like literally insane or if
they're just talking about like they
didn't like what he did like they
thought he was really
like arrogant and conceited and he did
all this like horrible [ __ ]
um but i think suetonius who
he wrote um about caligula i think 80 to
100 years after he had died
um and he said that uh
that maybe caligula had epilepsy
um some people have speculated maybe
meningitis uh maybe encephalitis so that
might um
you know encephalitis that causes like a
swelling of the brain
so that might have had something to do
with his behavior as well but it does
seem to be
that he seemed okay for the first
seven eight months of the reign and then
you know his arena's emperor and then he
got
whatever this mysterious illness was or
poisoning or whatever and then after he
came
out of it he was just this arrogant
[ __ ] who just wanted to kill
everybody and
all this other kind of stuff but like i
said some of the stuff is exaggerated
stuff about the horse
the stuff about [ __ ] his sisters and
all that kind of stuff
it's i'm not saying it didn't happen i'm
just saying there's not really any
contemporary
um you know evidence that it happened
but the [ __ ] that he did was like
horrible enough
it's just really funny how people tend
to remember
the thing about the horse probably more
than anything
you know when when you say caligula
people like oh the guy that made his
horse
even though like the [ __ ] that he did
that didn't really happen but then like
the [ __ ] that he did was so horrific
that it's like i'm surprised that people
don't remember that stuff
better you know what i mean um somebody
mentioned the
the movie caligula with malcolm mcdowell
in it which um
is really good but i mean only from the
porn aspect it's
yeah it's very porny in case you guys
haven't seen it
and i claudius also goes a lot into
caligula as well
um and that's also very good i haven't
seen the malcolm mcdowell caligula in
like a really really long time
it's probably tame i don't know um no
well i remember it being like pretty
much straight up a porno movie
i mean but it's been a long time since
i've seen it
um but and another thing too remember
like i was saying how
caligula was like real ugly and he was
like real pale and spindly and kind of
sickly looking and everything
i think also i heard that
he was like super super hairy and so
he was so hairy and he was like really
sensitive about it so like
no one could i think you couldn't like
say the word goat
in his presence or he'd like have you
killed because he was so sensitive about
a [ __ ] hair he was
and also i think he was balding and he
didn't like any so he didn't like
anybody being above him
you know what i mean so david so they
could see his
david's asking how he gets a pliskin
shirt uh if you live in the united
states just send us a super chat at
twenty dollars
and then contact jenny give her your
size and what and where
and your address and your address we're
gonna send some out in the next we gotta
make some tomorrow
yeah we're actually going to print some
tomorrow for because i have a couple
people that
wanted some and we i just got like the
size shirts that i ordered so we have to
print them tomorrow and mail them out
um i know this show has only gone on
three hours only only three only three
hours
good well then what do we do is five
warrants when it was five hours what the
[ __ ] were we thinking
how did we talk about the person i
couldn't get drunk on this because i'm
just like
i am so so so sleepy well because what
ended up happening was that
you know you know we were out last night
and then like i woke up at like quarter
to five because i had to pee
and then i couldn't go back to sleep so
i just laid there for like two hours
and then i think i fell back to sleep
for like 20 minutes but then you started
snoring and it woke me up
and then so i was laying there like for
another couple hours going man i
sure would like to go back to sleep but
then it was like nine o'clock and i was
like okay well i just i gotta get up
because i so i so i maybe only got like
if you can't send us a 20
super chat you can do it directly to
jenny's paypal you can contact her
i'll we'll send you one yeah so yeah
just uh
let me know the size and yeah sizing
your address and address some
stuff to paypal i'll send you one and uh
we'll get it all together because i have
like a bunch of blank shirts already
yeah um
it's just that a couple people one
somebody that requested one i had to
order one so i was gonna come up with
some new designs here in a bit too
victor says is there gonna be a
halloween special we actually are gonna
do
the show on halloween night live stream
just like we usually do
we got our costumes you've got all your
costumes yeah yeah
um i've got most of mine um i think i
have one more thing that i
still have to come and we have we're
still gonna do the voting
like on the topic but i'm gonna pick
like five different like halloween
centric
uh topics and then you guys can vote on
those and then we'll do we'll just do
like a fun
we'll have some candy we'll have like a
halloween party might have to go like
answer the door if trick-or-treaters
knock i don't know if we're gonna have
any trick-or-treaters this year yeah we
will
because of covid we will
[Laughter]
but yeah so uh like i said i really
really
need to go get a glass of water and then
i need to go to sleep
yep because i am exhausted so sorry it
was only three hours is that bad
and i just got a message today like
somebody um somebody posted on my on our
facebook page
that uh it's like it's funny listening
to you guys old shows and you start
freaking out if you go like over an hour
like oh my god we've been on so long and
it's like nowadays i'm just like sorry
this
show's only three hours long a lot of
people that are listening
are either commuting or they're [ __ ]
truck drivers
or they're laying in bed asleep and you
know they're just trying to go to sleep
and
it's easy to fall asleep listening to us
no actually [ __ ] i'm almost falling
asleep listening to us
i go to sleep i go to sleep listening to
my favorite podcasters all the time man
[ __ ]
i'll just go to sleep listen to dan bell
his [ __ ] smoothie
dan bell has a great voice and i really
really like
i wish he would do for a little bit of
quiet time i wish he would do more of
those
yeah and then here i and i forgot how to
make that voice
i'll try to remember how to make this
dan bell this is the voice that you guys
like
yeah yeah he just has like such a great
voice i saw this thing and i think it
was a ghost
you know like what yeah because a lot of
us a lot of the quiet time ones are like
paranormal experiences that he had um
because what he does
he shoots like so much [ __ ] footage
like because he doesn't he does dead
malls he does like another dirty room
which is my favorite even though it's
totally disgusting
um and he does zach he's gay man you
need to [ __ ] you need to [ __ ]
he's not cute but you know [ __ ] he's
talented you might want to look at
he's funny yeah he's constantly looking
for a boyfriend i think
i think that dude lives on the road he
seemed well like i said he just must be
all over i don't i mean he does travel
around he said that
he's from baltimore that he lives in
baltimore but it's like he seems like
he's always
going somewhere like he's always on a
trip and he's got this voice and he's
going to relax you
you're gonna talk about the ghosts and
we'll talk about the dead balls
and then here we are look at that look
at the ball and the ball is dying
and there he goes he's wiping his nose
off to a better day
that's just that was funny we've we've
watched some of those dead mall ones
like
like
hundreds of times but he's only got
one's the quiet time ones i think that
was a new thing that he started because
he had like all this extra footage that
he had taken
that he's like well i don't really know
what i want to do with all this footage
that i
shot because it's like it's not like the
audio was [ __ ] up or it doesn't really
like fit in with like another video i
was making
so basically he just takes this footage
of him just like walking around
abandoned places
and he just like talks over it like you
know like i said paranormal experience
sort of like weird [ __ ] that happened to
him like when he was a kid or something
and he just has that great like low
voice and it's like really really nice
like to relax too
damn bill isn't his type and plus he's
married i think he might be married it's
hard to tell every time i see
the i think his boyfriend looks like a
different one but maybe
and then yeah well i can't remember what
that kid's name is that's always a kid
he's old he's younger than me but it's
like
he he's always they're always like um
traveling together dj maniac says that
uh
he was working a 10-hour shift in the
warehouse and this is podcast what gets
him through it
oh that's awesome uh david june says
he's got a good buzz going on the show
did his job
victor says apple podcast lets you play
the podcast at half speed so that's like
a 10 hour show
damn you could just listen to us talk
well
[Laughter]
all right let's go ahead and shut it
down yeah let's that's oh that's another
shirt we need to make shut
that [ __ ] shut that [ __ ] down
and be dressed up as negan with that
[ __ ] bat i'm gonna shut that [ __ ]
down
and then he's gonna hit me in the head
just like in my aisle pop out just like
[ __ ] said i'm gonna shut that [ __ ] down
that sounds like i can't remember he
said that but he said something like
that yeah he
shut that [ __ ] down with a [ __ ]
baseball bat see he was going to shut
that [ __ ] down
[Music]
i have somebody um michael from asari
night texted me last night he's like
have you been watching this new walking
dead thing and i'm like no man i'm still
like
like a season or two behind did he say
he's good well he's like i don't know
what it what this is with the teenagers
on it so i don't really know what he's
talking about i don't know if it's like
some new direction that it took or if
it's a spin-off
walking dead lost it because i said i
thought that they were talking about
doing a spin-off with daryl and carol
which i'm i'm there for that but um
because those are my two favorite
characters i'm not so sure about walking
dead anymore
but i haven't seen like i said i haven't
seen any of the new [ __ ] so i'll go in
there and like catch up on it one of
these days it's like when you don't make
me a believer again
well maybe they can't i just want to
give them a chance i want to see uh
season two of mandalorian
that is coming soon i hear that [ __ ] on
blu-ray i don't even wanna i'm not gonna
[ __ ] with disney
i have but i heard that's coming out
soon so we could we could probably get
somebody to
they need to sell that [ __ ] all a cart
they'd really make money if they would
just [ __ ] sell
sell those [ __ ] series all the card well
yeah i don't want to [ __ ] with disney
plus
that's what i mean because it's like
there's so many streaming services now
and it's like i can't afford to have all
the streaming services
because it's like you know we already
have netflix we already have we have
netflix and shutter
okay and it's like 2b is free so that's
like that's fine
but there you know there's [ __ ] that i
would like to see
on hulu but i'm not gonna pay for that
as well all right people are signing off
we gotta go
yeah when the crowd starts leaving it's
time for us
they're like shut that [ __ ] down
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here all right so
uh hopefully you guys enjoyed this show
and hopefully it was uh you know kind of
educational like school look he's even
leaving yeah i'm out and then
so remember if you like the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show
go to our patreon page patreon.com 13
o'clock podcast
you can even vote on upcoming movie
reviews and topics and things of that
nature get early access to stuff which
is neat
or if you would like to give a one-time
donation go to a paypal account you go
to our blog 13 o'clock
podcast.wordpress.com and there is a
link in the sidebar to a paypal account
if you would rather give a one-time
donation
and that'll do it for episode 218 about
caligula
we will see you guys tomorrow bye